That means [music] access to anything that like a talent manager
would give an actual celebrity. So, it access to a bounty board
or ad deals or lawyers or event organizers or professionals or
anything that actually matters. To summarize, Reddit moderators
should be treated like celebrities or influencers not because
Yeah, NO SHOT. NO SHOT. BRO, come on, man. You can't be throwing
out lines like this. This is this just rage bait? Is this just
pure rage bait? Is Stail doing this character just to get yelled
at? Does he just like getting yelled at?
Uh Stail released his video on being removed from LSF and it's
a banger. Everyone's talking about it. Literally everybody's
talking about the Stail
All right. If we're going to do the Stail thing, then let's do
the Stail thing, okay? The first thing that got linked to me
was the DGG Stail 2000 DGG of the Year video. I don't think I'm
going to go with that, all right? I don't think so. This is Moist
talking about the million-dollar scam show, the million-dollar
fan show, okay? This was a game show that was proposed to Mythic
Talent and and LSF. And it seems like nobody really did their
due diligence
getting into it. All right? So, we're going to speed this up.
We're going to go through some of this Moist stuff explaining
this Twitch streamer show feels like a huge scam. So, Moist posted
this first video and then I believe after this the show goes
down. >> Uh buddy of mine just sent me something that I
can promise you no one We're going to We're going to kick this
off. Let's do it. >> would accept for the people that were
paid to promote it. It is called Million Dollar Fan. It is a
show which is pitching a $20 prize pool for what seems to be
a load of horseradish. And in case you were wondering, yes, that
is an AI mansion on their front page of this contest. At least
from everything I can tell, it's an AI-generated mansion, which
immediately should let you know that you're dealing with some
high-quality content here. No reason not to trust that. I can't
believe anybody would be pitched this and actually think it's
legitimate. Like it takes 3 seconds Oh, man. It's particularly
bad that Stail would have gotten caught by this. But, I do think
that's going to be a huge thing. People I think people's idea
of what legitimate is and what like what's too far for a scam
is going to warp is is going to like fall is going to lag behind
technology, okay? With AI being able to vibe code, you should
be able to build you could have like feasibly an app that you
could install with people for your scams. Like you could get
all of this stuff built up, spun up, and working in a in a way
that's not immediately
understandable to somebody outside of tech. Right? You can get
that automatic. You get that [__] up immediately.
Now, this website was quite bad, but I do think people are going
to have to realize that scams are going to get a lot more sophisticated
going forward and you will have to do some due diligence where
you're talking to human beings.
Right? You will get fooled by stuff, absolutely. If you're not
If you're not willing to put any time into looking into things,
be rough. seconds of looking on their website to smell the poop.
[snorts] It is unbelievably foul. Like there is no world where
this happens. To put in perspective that price Okay. Now, that
doesn't necessarily apply to this website, which is people should
>> number 20 million dollars. That is significantly more
than Mr. Beast's Amazon show and would make it by far the highest
grand prize prize pool in any kind of like reality game show
history pretty much. All for a what I believe to be terrible
concept for a show as well about streamers' fans submitting clips
and then I guess going to a mansion or something. I'm still a
little confused cuz the information they offer is just nonsensical.
Like I feel like I have to be on fent to even begin to process
the words that I'm reading in what is supposed to be a contest.
So, I want to go through this. I want to really get into the
weeds here because this is mind-bogglingly stupid. This is a
special kind that I just can't even picture someone falling for.
Yet, some streamers have publicly promoted it. I'm assuming they
were paid to do so by their talent agency who was approached
by whoever's behind the million-dollar fan show to do this. So,
I imagine
So, someone at Mythic Talent got to be getting fired, okay? Mythic
Talent, if you guys are unaware, is the OTK run. We've heard
about Mythic Talent when we were reading and reviewing the Miskif
stuff because Miskif had Miskif was under Mythic Talent, okay?
Miskif was under this brand before.
All right? Asmongold under this brand. Every OTK member's under
this brand. Miskif was under this brand and then he signed a
Rumble deal that he didn't give them a cut of. So, that's the
big That's the center of the Miskif allegations, okay? Or the
Miskif lawsuits. Is that's one of the big things is they're trying
to claw back money that Miskif didn't send to them, okay?
Now, this talent agency represents some of the biggest streamers.
Kaceytron is on under this talent agency, right? Asmongold under
this talent agency.
Do they got Caedrel? I don't think they've got Caedrel, though.
No way, right? They don't. Okay. They've They've just got massive
streamers under this talent agency, though, okay? So, with so
many massive streamers under this talent agency, you'd think
they'd do some due diligence before getting said massive streamers
to promote their right? To promote some
scam bull.
Now, I say scam. I don't understand how they were planning to
make money. He went to audience. So, that it's like a little
thing? Yo, Globe Heart, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, dude. I don't know how they're planning to make money, but
it's like clearly it's not
Right? Anyway. >> Some people buy into it, which I just
I can't wrap my noodle around that. This is like the Fire Festival
of streamer shows, but even more outrageously dumb. They have
a streamer section here and I'm guessing they were all paid to
endorse this and I know in Extra Emily's case she just had a
statement on her stream after her community was letting her know
that they believe she had just promoted a scam to them with hawking
Million Dollar Fan Club. So, we'll go over her statement here
towards the end of the video. Checking in on the about us section
offers more questions than answers. It's so useless here. You
get about as much lore here as you do for the old Urgot League
of Legends. Okay, this is all total garbage, probably written
with AI. All right? I'm going to skip through it pretty quickly.
>> 20 million dollars coming from Who is the the professional
television crew here working on this? What like this is not providing
any actual information about the team behind Million Dollar Fan.
That should immediately raise some red flags that they're not
front-facing with who is even putting this on in the first place
or where this prize purse is coming from. Their about us section
is fundamentally just like a high schooler that's cramming for
a summer reading book report where they're trying to meet the
word count. This should immediately be raising red flags and
have you asking some questions like why are they not being more
forward with who is behind this? Is it the Rockefellers? Like
who are they protecting? The elusive man or something from Mass
Effect? Like where is this coming from? Who is putting this on
and who is putting this together? This about us section is nothing
but meaningless fluff gobbledygook that doesn't actually answer
anything or provide any real valuable information about this
production and who's responsible for it. And then when you go
further to their partners section, they have like a couple of
brands listed here. Their three listed affiliates are Malwarebytes,
Hide.me, and then that mystery affiliate in the middle there
is StubHub. I had to click on it to find that information out.
I was a little nervous that I was about to have my I Now, what
I'm guessing here is when they go with affiliates,
I I do I do think these are just companies that allow you to
that have like open affiliate programs. Like you can sign up,
you can make a And And maybe that's just the scam, right? Is
they want to get somebody who's going to click these affiliate
links and buy
Maybe that's all it was was they decided that, "Hey, I'll like
set this up and if people click this, you know, I'll get some
money and that'll be awesome." >> identity stolen or something
clicking on a random image from a sketchy website that links
me to something outside of it. And their proud partners section
actually had me laugh out loud, audibly giggling, not just blowing
air out of my nose. I literally laughed a hearty ho ho ho like
Santa when I saw Livestream Fail is listed as a proud partner
of Million Dollar Fan. And so, I went to the Livestream Fail
and they actually even had a big post announcing this to try
and get people to sign up for it. So, I guess they're like an
official partner of Million Dollar Fan. And I was reading the
comments from like one of the mods there that was talking about
it and it seems like he's completely clueless on what's even
going on in regards to this whole thing. So, I don't exactly
understand their role in this or like who's pulling the strings
there, the puppet master at LSF that's partnering with Million
Dollar Fan, but the mods don't even seem to be on the same page
there and don't have any real answers. And going to IRL Buffs
is like going to a barren wasteland. This whole website is completely
empty. It's like Squiggly we're going to that room to be all
alone. This feels like it's a prototype that was thrown together
in like a handful of minutes just for the sole sake of existing
on the Million Dollar Show site. I'm pretty sure that's an AI-generated
image there as well for their products like anti-tilt and aimbot.
Like this whole thing is extremely sketchy to me. There's like
no actual information on this website at all. It is just trash.
And then their third listed partner
Dude, we should have clicked through. I I looked at this for
a second. I was like, "Okay, it's a scam, whatever." We should
have clicked through it a little bit more. There was a little
more content here right now. >> Robot Wars or whatever,
that doesn't go anywhere. You You can't You can click the image,
but nothing happens. So, when it says coming soon, it literally
means coming soon. One of their partners, they're still imagineering
right now. They have the concept of a partner, but it doesn't
actually exist. It's This whole thing I truly don't know how
anyone could be pitched this and just say like, "Oh, yeah, I'll
put my name on that." Now, I ended up making an account, Gilman
Tuskus. I used 10-minute mail. I set up my account. And it seems
like there's a lot of monetization here. So, you can buy some
emote packs up to $5.50 worth of creator emote packs, which give
you 10 entries into the competition, but they do Oh, that's the
scam, then. Okay, they actually monetize the site for people
to sign up for the site. I see the scam
Oh, dude, they definitely
They definitely made some money off of this. I don't know if
they made their money back, but that's the scam is they're just
going to get people to sign up and get additional entries, right?
Okay, that's the scam. >> make clear numerous Okay, this
is definitely just a scam, then.
Like 100% it's just obviously a scam. I'm sorry. It's really
obviously a scam. Come on. times no purchase is necessary to
enter, but kind of nudging you a little bit to maybe make a couple
purchases, but you can't legally require a payment. You can't
legally require someone to buy something in order to enter into
some [__] like this. So, that's there to cover their
own ass in the eyes of the law, but they do very much try and
incentivize you to spend money here for the Million Dollar Fan
Show. Uh going to their official rules, I thought for a brief
moment I was going to learn more about the sponsor here, but
it's talked so vaguely that it sounds like a Destiny 2 raid boss.
The sponsor, Million Dollar Fan reality >> Okay. So, from
here he goes to talking about like Extra Emily's reaction to
it, all right? And from what I've seen of extra the reaction
Extra Emily once it comes out that this is more of a scam thing,
okay? I do believe that once you get to like the the Emily stuff,
she says, "Well, Mythic Talent came to me with this and I didn't
look into it." And nobody gave her the pass. So, I I feel like
it's going to be rough if that's Stail's only reaction to this.
We'll see. Okay, I'm going to I'm I'm skipping forward to the
Extra Emily bit cuz I I only we only like context here, okay?
Like context from Charlie. We'll watch his a little bit of his
follow-up video as well and then we'll go into the Stail video,
okay? >> This being in there is trying to stop someone
like discourage them from coming after them in the event that
this doesn't actually happen, which I again, if you do get scammed
by this, I don't think these terms protect them. I'm not a [__]
lawyer, but I don't think it actually would really even do much
in that case. Anyway though, let's move on to the next component
of this, which was Extra Emily's response when people were calling
it out. >> I'm not I I know it's sus. I know it looks sus,
okay? Uh Mythic pitched it to me and I was like, "Okay, sounds
good." But I just don't want LSF to be part of it. Like are you
kidding me? Like why is there an LSF person? Like like they're
like you must be like, "Oh, Emily is is backing it up." And I'm
Oh, NO. OH, NO. NO.
EXTRA EMILY, NOT YOU TOO. EXTRA, NO.
DUDE. Uh LSF.
LSF, clearly clearly scam scam website scamming all of my audience.
I sleep.
Associating me with Stale and LSF, uh no no no. I don't want
to be associated with them. Get the [__] Get out
of here,
I'm like, "I just posted it cuz I have to. Like I had to be like,
okay, I'm going to tell people about it." Pardon? What do you
mean you only posted about it cuz you had to? You didn't have
to. You could have said no to this when they approached you.
Like you make it sound like this it was an obligation she couldn't
avoid. You didn't have to Wait, I know Charlie is involved in
Starforge Systems.
He can't be involved in Mythic Talent, right? Charlie has his
own talent thing.
I think that's separate from Mythic. I don't think he could be
involved in Mythic Talent. I think that would probably be wrong.
Right? I think Does he not know about contractual sponsors? Yeah,
that's like you could have something to Like I'm not sure what
you get to turn down, to be honest with you.
I'm not sure if she could turn it down. It might be in her contract
or something with with Mythic to like go and support this, right?
If she's approached with it. >> accept the deal. And she
even talks about how she like didn't really look into it and
just said sounds good off rip. Why? Why why wouldn't you even
bother to take like a single beep at it? Especially when they're
approaching you about a $20 million contest that uses fans and
you as like the face of it. That's That is inconceivable to me.
And then she's like really surprised that the LSF
If they pitched it to her and she said, "Sure, sounds good."
I would say to me
truly the blame there does lie on
It's like it it is on Mythic. That is literally their only job
is to look at look into sponsors, vet them, and then say, "Okay,
we're going to we're going to work with these people, right?"
I guess you'd have to look into I Dude, it's yeah, it's bad.
It's really bad for Mythic. Given that Mythic is again the the
company that takes What was the thing from the Miskif stuff?
Was it 20% they took? Hold on, we need to actually go find that
real
Where would we find that? How quick How quickly could I find
that for us? Cuz that's really Dude, you're paying them 20% like
Mythic should be basically refunding Extra Emily at this point,
right? Cuz god damn, that's crazy. They take I think they take
20% or something like that.
They're taking 20% of all earnings from from anything they find
her and they're going to bring her that dog [__]
That's nuts, man.
I know I know I keep watching I guess it's just like one person
maybe on the LSF mod squad that posted that statement. She's
surprised that they're saying she's backing it up. She's like,
"Why would they even think I'm backing it up?" Because you are.
You you you you are. You you promoted it. That is you backing
it up. You were on their website. What do you like what I don't
understand why that's not like registering. But then the LSF
guy's like, "Oh yeah, Extra Emily totally like backed it." I'm
like, "I don't know what I'm supposed to do, okay?" So I don't
know what's happening, but for now just like put like put this
put on the side, okay? So I will get more information on it and
then let you guys know. So yeah, but I I promise I'm like not
trying to scam you guys. I apologize I didn't do more research
beforehand. Um but I'm going to have them do more research. >> And
Ninja Joel keep them updated on on all of that. Again they're
saying you're backing it up because you did promote it. You were
on their website as one of streamers that you can go in and be
part of the fan sweepstakes for. The images that I put there
of like the email packages on my Gilman Tucker's account, I did
that. Okay. Okay, okay. I think we're good here. We understand
the scam enough. I'm going to go to the second Charlie video,
okay? This is after he goes over the whole thing. They they rip
everything down and he looks further into it, okay? We're going
to watch a little bit of this and then we're going to get into
the stale video. I might cover there's some extra stuff here
as well of Stale reacting in DGG. We'll we'll take a look around,
okay? >> ago. If you think I look tired well, you better
get your eyes checked, buster. That's a certified WebMD diagnosable
moment right there that something has gone awry with your peepers.
Uh Charlie talks about his his quite a bit. Wow. Cha- Charlie
has insomnia, guys.
Checkmate. Point is, in my endless battle against insomnia, I
happen to have stumbled across something interesting again this
evening and it
I think they had other people approached for the show, possibly
all of Mythic, I don't know, but you can see placeholder pages
with their names on Google. Oh,
Interesting. Interesting. >> video about the $20 reality
TV show Twitch streamer fan production extravaganza
mansion beer rock and roll whatever else it was pitching itself
as called the Million Dollar Fan Show. Well, I speculated that
it was a big scam and a lot of Twitch streamers had been publicly
put on the website. Some had even made announcements about their
endorsement of the Million Dollar Fan Show and nothing about
it seemed legitimate. I'm not just going to regurgitate everything
from last night's video. You can check that out if you want a
deeper dive on everything that was wrong with it. But the last
night on stream like 45 minutes after I posted the video, they
took their website down. Then I was checking their other ancillary
and all of that is removed. It seems like they're scrubbing any
existence of the Million Dollar Fan Show from the internet. So
like even the Reddit post that the livestream fan mods posted
is taken down. I don't know if that was by order of the Million
Dollar
Illuminati or if the mods that had signed an agreement with them
had a come to Jesus moment that they may have been misled so
they decided to take it down, but apparently also removed like
their Discord and their socials, which is a huge blow by the
way because the Million Dollar Fan Show had like five Instagram
followers. So really playing a sad song on the world's smallest
violin now that five Instagram followers have been cast into
oblivion banished to the shadow
Sorry, I'm not going to I'm going to comment on this. I'm trying
to find What I'm really trying to find here is what the percentage
that Mythic was taking What What was the percentage Mythic was
taking from Miskif? I do believe we get that in the Miskif documents
and it feels quite important just to drive home
how much money these people must be
and like the level of due diligence diligence you should be expecting
from them. It's just they're trying to run this scam for long
enough to get a couple purchases. They're probably looking at
like 10 to 50 grand is what they're looking to make off of this,
I would imagine. >> I feel like that's pretty strong evidence
for my game theory that it was all a big load of hullabaloo,
a bunch of hooey. I don't think a legitimate company that's putting
together a $20 grand prize reality show that is also a television
program that is also employing some of the highest level production
staff imaginable for a once-in-a-lifetime unforgettable experience
for streamer fans. Also their about us section had all the telltale
signs of just being AI generated where literally every section
ended with triplets where it was, you know, it's not this, it's
this. Performance, power, mentality. Mentality. Mentality. Like
it just like it was very clearly AI generated. The first thing
you see on their website is an AI generated image of a mansion.
The whole thing just reeked of scam. And now everything has been
deleted presumably by them. I don't think, you know, some governing
body came into, you know I was muted. I was just about to say
I do I was muted. I was muted this time. I was actually muted
this time. That's my bad. That's my bad, okay.
So for the sake of looking through this do we feel like I feel
like I've got the context I need to know the level of due diligence
required to figure out that this was a scam? Um how obvious a
scam it seems to be?
Right? And I'm more I'm more thinking about like
Okay, what questions would we ask Stale based off of this? It's
like, "Okay, what What did you Who approached you to partner
on this? And what did they tell you? And then what due diligence
did you do outside of what they told you?" Because for Emily
I understand Emily is giving these people a chunk of their of
her earnings.
I understand for Emily how she has trust in them, right?
For Stale, when he's not getting a chunk of their earnings, I
do think there's like probably some due diligence that is uh
you know, it's incumbent on him to do it because he is the leader
of LSF. It's a separate organization. It's a separate thing,
right?
I understand Extra Emily just you know, "Oh, whatever. I'll do
it if you say it's good, I'll do it." I get it. They're a little
bit, okay? For Stale, I don't think he has that same excuse.
>> So wipe them out. I think this is them trying to cover
their own ass so that way there isn't some kind of legal action
taken against them cuz from what I've read, there were actually
some members of some streamer communities that put money into
the Million Dollar Fan Show. They bought email packages. I read
a report on someone that claims to have spent a couple hundred
dollars doing so. So I imagine there was a handful of people
that did legitimately lose money on this. Yeah, not good, man.
Not good. >> to back it up, especially now that everything
is deleted. There's nothing to prove that, but I'm inclined to
believe those statements from them because these streamers are,
you know, to a lot of people a trustworthy source. And if they're
endorsing something and they say that there's a chance that they
can win $20 or whatever the [__] through like signing
up for it, they will do so. And when you go to the website and
do their free sign up, they're very heavily pushing you to do
the monetize sign up for unlimited entries by giving them money.
So I bet a lot of them were baited into doing that. Now, as I
said in the last video, I am shocked that Mythic Talent actually
even floated this to their creators like Extra Emily. She in
her statement mentioned Mythic Talent by name that they had pitched
it to her. I was surprised it made it to a streamer because anyone
that even had their eyes open and neurons firing for a second
would go to that website and know full well immediately right
from the jump that this is not real, that this is fraudulent.
So I did a little digging and I was able to get in contact with
an agent, not at Mythic, but at another agency that did have
this exact same thing come across their desk for their stream.
Oh. Wa- Hold on.
Now I'm interested. Oh, why didn't I wish he'd lead with that
at the beginning of the video. I almost I almost skipped through.
I was like about to move on. No, this is critical
What did another agency get? What What did the packet look like?
What were they told? Now he says, "Oh, this came across my Dude,
I think he owns an agency. I wonder Dude, I wonder if Charlie's
been sandbagging this whole time. I wonder if Charlie and through
his agency, I wonder if they got the same offer, the same approach
and they went, "Oh, this is an obvious scam." And so he knew
making the first video that he could expose this scam to people,
right? Make that other AGENCY LOOK BAD.
OH, THAT'S IN MY HEAD. THAT'S WHAT'S GOING on here, actually.
Charlie knows, "Oh, this is an obvious scam." And Mythic's like
pedaling it to their
Oh, that's embarrassing. Oh, we do a little we do a little we
do a little
We do we do a little video. streamer clients as something to
That seems obvious, right? That he would clearly want to do that.
It's like him taking advantage of like a a competitor totally
failing in all of their obligations. pitch to them. And according
to that agent, I don't know how deep into the nitty-gritty I'm
allowed to get, what they sent them the pitch deck was extraordinarily
from what ended up making it to that website. From what I understand
and from what I have been told, they were under the impression
that this was an Amazon-backed production, at least initially.
And at the time of receiving this offer, they didn't have a website
or anything public outside of that pitch deck, I guess they were
hawking to agencies. And it is indeed a paid promotion. The streamers
that are listed there were paid for this partnership. And there
was no additional information available beyond the concept of
the show and the promise that Amazon was behind a historic $20
million streamer fan hullabaloo reality TV show. Now, one of
the streamers also sent me the exact offer that was presented
to them, which gives further confirmation to all of this. It
comes from Mythic. This is the direct offer from Mythic that
this streamer received. I'm not going to show the actual thing
so that way no one gets into legal hot water here. I don't want
to, you know, step on too many Legos, but I will give you the
general overview for what the pitch was, the offer. Interestingly
enough, >> the offer came back in June of 2025 from Mythic.
And the opening line was about how it's an Amazon series. This
is an Amazon series looking to break records, a historic $20
million prize purse reality show. It doesn't even name the show,
by the way. I'm guessing back in June of 2025 they didn't even
have the name of the show or anything concrete. There was no
website, no mention of like LSF or brand partners.
Okay, by the way, you can just put video you like have to basically
sign up and you have to have
it self-publishing to Amazon Prime is or Prime Video is not difficult,
okay? The bar is not high. That can no longer be the bar for
like, "Oh, this show is like actually means something." They're
not even paying, right? Like people think, "Oh, it's a show on
Prime Video. Prime Video is paying for this con- content." No.
No. Don't use that as a bar anymore. Prime Being on Prime Video
means nothing. It means literally nothing, okay? Is anything
like that. It was It was just a single sentence that said, "Amazon
reality TV show set to air on Amazon Prime featuring the soon-to-be
broken Guinness World Record Book for biggest prize pool in history,
$20 million winning group splits money in half, $10 million to
you and $10 million to the fan." That is the entire explanation
for what this deal was. Uh interestingly enough, like I said,
June of 2025, the deliverables were in a reality TV show appearance,
1 to 7 days, depending on how far you make it, and a single social
post. The initial filming date was November 3rd to November 10th,
but I'm guessing, you know, some wires got crossed there, you
know, nipple clamps came down, you know, maybe government shut
down, you know, put that on the back burner had to put the kibosh
on that and shelved it till I guess 2026. Anyway though, they
were offering $3,000 for the streamer involvement here, plus
20% of net ticket sales from your ticket, which the streamer
expressed some confusion over because they didn't believe Mythic
knew that there was like this paid entry option, but in the offer
it says they were getting 20% of net ticket sales. When you go
knowing now, you know, hindsight is 20/20,
Yeah, 7-day I It is It's one of those things that people get
used to this. And I I understand why people are used to this
cuz a lot of people, you know, during COVID when money was literally
worth nothing, stuff like this would pop up and it would be it
would exist, right? People throw millions of dollars at [__]
and there would be nothing there, but all it would all fall apart,
it would all be dog [__] right?
$20 million today, that's too much for like a a hope and a prayer
with no reputations behind it, with nobody like no face to it.
That's Yeah, you can immediately cast that aside as
And again, as somebody pointed out, I think Moist pointed out,
it's like more than Mr. Like for the Mr. Beast games, it's like
more than was being given away for that. It just makes no sense
when you think about it. >> going to the website that existed,
when you would sign up through a streamer portal, you were paying
for those entries if you wanted to extend beyond just the free
submission. So, I'm thinking that the idea from this offer was
that when someone, a fan of the streamer, did a paid entry through
their portal, they would get a portion of that. So, like I feel
like Mythic would have had to have known that there was some
kind of like paid component to the fans, but who knows? There's
so little information here in the actual offer that Mythic told
the streamers. I'm still extremely surprised it even made it
to a single streamer as something to consider. I don't know why
there wouldn't be more digging to confirm if this is actually
even an Amazon show, because after the offer they didn't go into
like a general explanation for it. And it is so bare-bones, it
sounds like something that a person would cook up in 5 minutes
while taking a [__] after consuming like, you know,
their morning oats or something. There's not a whole lot of thought
into this. Competition details: one creator, one fan group eliminated
per day, $20 cash prize, one creator, two fans. They will be
gaming IRL and cognitive challenges. Think Survivor, but for
creators. And then it just lays out Cognitive challenges, >> like
the most simple, boring [__] ever for the competition,
and then the apocalypse challenge on day three, during which
fans will compete head-to-head with each other, resulting in
a mass elimination, narrow the group
Uh So, each creator is ultimately paired with one of their original
fans for the last 4 days. It It's like it's if you went to like
a Redditor and asked them to really quickly come up with a streamer
game show or something. Now, as for the initial start date of
November, the streamer was just told that it got pushed back
to March. I don't think there was any like real explanation for
what went wrong, you know, maybe bad weather, perhaps government
shut down, you know, all kinds of possibilities for why it got
moved, but they weren't really, you know, kept up-to-date, kept
abreast on everything going on here with this huge giant Amazon
show. I am even more surprised that any agency would have seen
this and just shipped it as is, just said, "We'll do it live.
We'll send it out to our streamers to see if they'll accept the
$3,000 offer with the the 20% ticket sales split or whatever."
Because like I feel like when you were getting this as, you know,
pitched as an Amazon production, you would probably want to confirm
if this is actually coming from Amazon. Because if you're going
to work with this agency managing these kind of contracts and
There There it is, right? That's the first thing is So, Amazon
It's going to be on Amazon Prime Video, guys. Okay, did Amazon
pay for it or are you just putting it up there yourself?
Cuz it sounds like there's some way that people do this Prime
Video [__] and they don't have any money from Amazon
coming in and they just use it for prestige, right? Lots of businesses
do this. It's a very common thing in the business world. They'll
say, "We have these affiliates. The affiliation is like totally
tenuous. It basically means nothing, right?"
Uh one second.
Got it. Had to sneeze there. Yeah, it's it's a very common thing
in the business world to present yourself as partners with a
really big company to provide yourself some level of, "Oh, we
look really good."
And it seems like there's some people
in the streamer world who just don't understand this.
Sounds Yeah, yeah, Pepper Jack, it is very much like that. What
the [__] was that sneeze? Uh it was exaggerated for
the stream so you guys could hear it. I wanted it to be verbal
or I wanted it to pick up through the noise filter. And stuff.
But you're working under the impression that no one's going to
tell lies on the internet. What's stopping just any old Joe Schmo
Dorito-dusted fingers from sending you a cold call email saying
like, "Hey, this is me, Amazon, pitching you a 50 quadrillion
dollar reality television show. I'll offer like $3,000 with some
revenue split to your streamers. Do you mind taking this to them?
I'd love for them to start shouting out goochsweat.org soon.
It's a very legitimate reality TV show. We're Amazon, by the
way." And you not press that any further cuz that's what it feels
like. Looking at the offer, there is no actual information about
like Amazon being behind this. And since this was back in June
of 2025, I can understand the absence of a website a little bit
more back there because if this is like an Amazon show, they're
probably not going to make the website first and foremost because
they don't want to like spoil it or anything. Like I can kind
of understand that. So, streamers being left in the dark on,
you know, like a website they think they can access. Like this
website, it didn't So, did we I'm wondering So, apparently they're
getting $3,000. Apparently this company came with a little bit
of money right off the bat.
I You asked about a production the production company? Yeah,
but there's dude, there's weird production companies out there
that will There I think there's starting to be like some industrial
complex of if you're a production company, you'll sign stuff,
you'll like say you're making something. I do think there's some
[__] like that,
There it is. >> Charlie's actually doing a really good
job covering this. I feel like this is way outside Charlie's
normal stuff. Charlie normally is like the high-level, I'm going
to get details wrong, I'm just going to kind of get the word
out there, I'm going to collect some money off of this. Charlie
doing like a really good job of looking into this. This is like
the best Charlie video The two best Charlie videos I've watched
ever.
What the [__] What happened?
What happened to Charlie? What happened to the old Charlie? The
guy who just phones it in all the time. What happened What happened
there? Jesus, my voice is gone. This is according to the streamer,
it just recently popped up, which What happened? who is, that
does appear to be the case, even though the domain had been registered
for a while. It was updated in like late December. So, that's
probably when it actually went live, which is when anyone could
go on there and see how fraudulent it was with just a single
[__] glance. So, I do now understand that there were
streamers that literally couldn't look up this show because the
offer doesn't even have the You got that That's the only thing
that makes sense to me, Whisper in the Dark, is that Charlie
has
>> his own sponsorship agency. He probably got brought
something like this. They identified or sifted out pretty quickly
that it was a scam. And he's like shocked that Mythic didn't.
And he's basically just burying Mythic for it. name of the show
and the website didn't exist. What I'm still confused on is like
why anyone would still accept that deal. And then I start to
understand a bit more that they just have trust in the agency
not to be presenting them with a scam. They had trust that the
Mythic Talent, for example, like in Extra Emily's case, was bringing
them something that was legitimate. So, they're seeing like,
"Oh, it's an Amazon show that wants to work with me and they're
making this offer. Okay, this seems like a big deal. I'll I'll
sign up to that and, you know, do the social post or whatever."
Also, if you try and look up million dollar fan.show now, the
most recent update to the site was today because the update was
just nuking it, taking it down. But prior to that, it was updated
in late December, which is when I imagine this went live. So,
now it seems like the streamers literally didn't even have access
to look up the information themselves on that website, which
again doesn't take a super sleuth, you know, pinky up internet,
you know, narwhal baking baking at midnight master to see that
that is a disaster of a website that is clearly in a shady spot,
most likely looking to scam. The streamers didn't know that site
was there because the deal was all the way back in June. Though
I will say, looking at the offer, this should have been something
that I think streamers should have been a little wary of because
it just it feels like it is very odd just looking at it. But
I think that does fall a bit more on the agency than it does
the streamer itself because there is a level of trust from streamers
with the person that is like managing their brand deals >> what
they are getting is not just toilet paper that's trying to wipe
their ass with their fans. The whole purpose of giving them a
bunch of money to manage that, giving them like a piece of the
pie there, is that you're delegating it, right? You are intentionally
delegating out that job to
That's the whole point. They're not supposed to have to go, "Well,
I'm going to look into this really closely
The people who are giving Mythic thousands of dollars to represent
them, some tens or possibly even hundreds of thousands of dollars
to represent them a
Yeah, that's entirely on Mythic, dude. Come on. >> And
in this case, I'm still just shocked that it even made it to
the streamers in the This should have been probably caught far
earlier. I imagine they could have confirmed it well beyond this,
like almost a year later, that this wasn't Amazon behind it if
they had like, set up like calls or something or look for any
level of proof of this being Amazon, like even just questioning,
"Where is this money coming from? Who else are we working with?
What is the actual production timeline and all of that looking
like?" I feel like there was definitely a way like Mythic Talent
could have caught this and then never even had to get to this
point where there were real victims where uh based on what I've
read, there were people that wouldn't like hundreds of dollars,
which again, I know you have to take with a grain of salt cuz
there's no like evidence to support those claims that people
lost a ton of money since everything is scrubbed, but I'm inclined
to believe them because the audience has a level of trust in
the streamer that what they are pitching is not just a scam that's
going to just rob their [__] piggy banks. So, I do
think that there were real victims here and I think it was just
so easily avoid By the way, that was Charlie at 2x the whole
time. >> It's just [__] wild that it even happened.
RIP Million Dollar Show. Do you think that's why Charlie is like
hitting with people? Do you think enough people watch at two
to three X like YouTube videos that Charlie is actually like
nobody actually watches Charlie at 1x and that explains like
why people watch him? Like watching him at 1x people are like,
"Oh, this guy's like really slow, monotone, boring." But actually,
if you speed him up to 2x, he sounds kind of normal. 1.5 x 2x
he sounds kind of normal. >> Definitely feels like it was
a scam from the get-go considering they have just vanished, poofed
out of existence, and erased every trace that they were ever
even here to begin with. Anyway though, that's really about it.
Yeah. Okay.
So from this this is 3 days ago we do eventually move over to
Let me see if I can find
We've got a Reddit post here. So Stale himself gets taken out
from from LSF. This is a day ago. Okay. Stale gets removed as
a mod of LSF. We covered this on stream a little bit. Stale himself
he commented to me a little bit, he commented on in DGG chat
a little bit, which we can go over those. All right. I think
we got two tweets here. Here's the logs he had
before producing the video. Right here. Here Stale is getting
pressed by members of DGG over a scam he allegedly promoted,
which presumably seems to be stemming from the same allegations
that have led to his removal from the r/livestreamfail moderation
team. How cancel am I? Address the scam you tried to promote.
I frankly don't have any info right now. I'm waiting for people
with actual >> to come forward.
Why is their picture still there? Weird. Okay. All right. So
>> So we talked about this with him. I We figured it out
from talking to him as well that that's what happened, right?
That he was removed explicitly for
He was removed explicitly. Oh, this is after the video. Hold
on, isn't it? This is after the video. We do this after the video.
Okay. So he was explicitly removed for the scam stuff, okay?
And he's going to elucidate that in his video. We tried to get
him on last night. He wanted to make his video. He wanted to
record it and get it out. Um I From what I've seen in this video,
it's less than ideal, okay? It's in my opinion a little less
than ideal. I I would not have published this video personally.
I'm going to I'm going to talk about
Yeah, okay. Uh he's coming on here in a little bit. I'm not concerned
about this Stale boys is thing. We're going to We're going to
watch this. We'll watch the video. Okay.
The opening line is not great and there's one comment here in
the first like 30 seconds that I sort of lost my mind over very
specifically. Let's see if you can sense it.
Uh play play play play play play play >> Mr. CEO of Reddit.
I hope you have received the Okay, right off the bat.
What's the filter, bro?
I'm immediately I'm immediately less likely to listen to you
because of whatever filter is happening here.
This looks like
You look like a hologram or something. What in the is happening
with this filter? What is going on? What? It's such a weird filter
to put on. >> this public video that I have created and
sent to you via your email. Hello Spez, Mr. CEO of Reddit. I
hope you have received this public video that I have created
and sent to you via your email. Now I I'll be honest, I should
have helped Stale out on this cuz he he dropped this first line
to me
in DMs and he said, "This is the first line." And he said it
and I was like
I don't think that that it doesn't hit the way you think it hits.
But I didn't say anything. So that's my bad. I should have let
him know that like you're saying I hope you've received this
email that I've emailed to you or this video that I've emailed
to you. I just I don't think that hits. I think he was like,
"Well, I'm going to the CEO of Reddit." I'm going above everybody.
But it's I don't know.
I don't know, man. He's got the PowerPoint ass presentation in
the back background in the background here. Yeah. It's like this
is straight up of out of like Microsoft Office 2000, this background.
Not not I hope anybody who cares about the topic in this video
can get this to him in any way that you can. This video is about
a topic of deadly seriousness and that is of Reddit moderation
and the Right there, first 20 seconds, I'm gone. I'm gone. I'm
launched into space I can no longer
deal with this video, Stale. That's That is an insane thing to
say. That is
Please. Hard to believe he's being
Where's the Don't you There's no irony to this. He's Every other
comment around it is serious. I understand that there's some
element people think he's playing into a character, okay?
But no none of the other things discussed here are jokes or
So I I understand some people might think it's a joke, it's a
it's a character I'm playing into it. Maybe.
But then people are going to treat this like a joke and they're
going to mock you. You understand like the thing if you're not
serious here, then it's just you that's going to get mocked.
And by the way, I do think he means because this is technically
addressing Spez that he does mean deadly seriousness for you
as the guy who runs LSF. Sorry, who the guy who runs Reddit.
Uh I think this is all serious. All serious. I personally believe
this is all serious, okay? You can't convince me it's not. >> cares
about the topic in this video can get this to him in any way
that you can. This video is about a topic of deadly seriousness
and that is of Reddit moderation and the state of your platform.
But first, some background. I'm Brian or Stale2000 or TarotCard.
I was the top moderator of your number one gaming subreddit r/livestreamfail
before I was recently removed from that position by the Reddit
Code of Conduct team. I became a Reddit moderator for one reason
and that is because I think that Reddit communities and correspondingly
its moderators have massive power and influence and for some
reason nobody seems to notice, care, or take this seriously.
Dude, I Dude.
I There is some influence to Reddit moderator or Reddit moderation,
okay? You got a big subreddit, there's some influence to it.
I won't say that he's wrong here, okay? That's That's not incorrect,
okay? Especially even on LSF. If you own LSF, if you're the top
moderator on there that's not necessarily incorrect, right? And
I don't think There's a lot of people in chat who are laughing
at that who I think would also get mad at the idea that like
DGG controls LSF, right? They'd also be like, "Oh, well, Destiny
controls LSF." They'd say this and then they You can't make fun
of him and take that seriously at the same time. You know what
I'm saying? Either that matters or it doesn't matter. I would
say it does matter. It's just weird to see somebody take it seriously,
okay?
Yeah, it's not something to flaunt. It's
It It's a little weird. I get it. I get why people get put off
by the video, okay? I know. >> by the Reddit Code of Conduct
team. I became a Reddit moderator for one reason and that is
because I think that Reddit communities and correspondingly its
moderators have massive power and influence and for some reason
nobody seems to notice, care, or take this seriously. I know.
You'd like to see people who become moderators because they really
like a community, they really like a topic, right? And they want
to make sure that the conversation on that topic is like
something other people want to participate in. Right? Instead
of Well, I became a Reddit moderator cuz power attracts me, okay?
I I I These are powerful people and nobody takes that power seriously.
Man, I don't know, man. I
It's It is weird. And I do think So he's talked about this. This
isn't his only reason, okay? He's also talked about Reddit moderation
and how important it is in the in terms of wanting to become
a mod because he was an engineer at Twitch and I think he worked
on clips.
And all of the creators would come to him as the engineer who
worked on clips and be like, "Can we Can you stop them from posting
it to LSF?"
Like a lot of creators got mined by LSF and so he specifically
was like, "I'll be the guy who sort of fixes this for creators."
That's a That's a missing piece here that I don't think he talks
about as much or maybe he'll bring it up later in the video,
but that is the underlying thing is he was talking to creators
because he was a big Twitch He was a big fan of Twitch streamers.
He was on the Twitch staff and creators would constantly complain
about LSF and he wanted to fix that relationship. He wanted to
be the person who made that work, right? I do believe that's
why he signed up to be a mod and eventually became head mod of
the subreddit. least of all its moderators or the company. In
this video So that's There's a parasocial para-sociality element
here that you can't really discount or or put off to the side.
I do think some element of para-sociality drove his want to be
an LSF moderator. >> You I will go over why I believe this
and I will also talk about a code of conduct moderation action
that was taken against me due to good faith mistakes that I believe
were caused by a clear lack of direct material support that the
company gives its moderators. I will end the video by talking
about WHAT YOU OH, SH So wait, you made a mistake here and it
was caused by them? Okay. what Spez can do to fix this problem
as well as what I and other communities can do in case Reddit
does not solve this very serious mismanagement problem regarding
the lack of support that is given to moderators. First, I will
go over the code of conduct action and why I was removed as the
top moderator of r/livestreamfail.
This sounds like stupid internet drama, I know, but I'm going
to talk about how this is a very clear example about how Reddit's
mistakes causes very serious problems to Reddit's community and
the company as a whole. Here's what happened. There was an announcement
related to a live stream related game show called Million Dollar
Fan. It was
a game show like survivor or Big Brother where fans of a streamer
compete in different challenges with a you know an influencer
or a streamer for various prizes. The kicker here is that there
was a grand prize of 20 million dollars supposedly. This was
supposedly going to be aired on Amazon Prime and it was also
confirmed to be including a couple of mid-sized and large streamers
like Alexander [snorts] and Andrea Botez, Extra Emily, Knut
Dude, who's Did the Botez twins suck at validating their sponsors,
okay?
The Botez twins hear the their names attached to this and they
got to just be like rolling their eyes. They got to be super
upset. Oh no, people are going to come at us again.
>> Is this better or worse than the Dubai
What do you guys think? >> and a few other Crypto scams,
Dubai thing. Again, they've they've again done this exact thing
again.
Additionally, the opportunity was supposedly brought to the streamers
by a company called Mythic Talent, which is a
streamer agency that represents hundreds of live streamers. I
>> I mean, after this, well-respected? I don't know, man.
This is like rough. Like I
How Who takes this talent agency seriously at this point?
Like this is They've totally [__] the bed. They've
totally obliterated their credibility. It's gone.
I heard about the game show a few hours after it got announced
by a couple major live streamers. It sounded like the perfect
type of content for Live Stream Fail. I mean, reality Oh god,
I Dude, there's no way. What? What? Why? Why? Why was this done?
Why was this done?
Why was this Why? Why?
Hold on. Wait. Wait. I I'm so sorry, Stail. I'm so I hope you
still come on. I It had to be It has to be done. I It has to
be done. THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO. IT HAS TO BE DONE. reality
TV, game show, live streaming, gaming,
you know, that's perfect for LSF, which is about fun crazy content
about kind of live streaming gamers. So when I heard about this,
I was very excited. I immediately reached out to the organizers
to see if we could set up some sort of a collaboration. This
collaboration would just be to get cool content on the subreddit.
No, you know, financial incentives, no moderators being paid,
basically none of anything like that, just fun cool stuff for
the community in the subreddit. For collaborations, the Okay.
Now, you could say this, but Stail has to understand
Oh, no, I don't want the music for me, okay? You could say this,
okay, well, listen, it's just supposed to be we didn't get paid,
we just promoted it, it's just for like collaborations. You could
say that, but then how do they know in any case if you're not
attached to the scam? I will just be taping. Hold on. Reuben
Reuben donated $3.
Hi Swains Dale. Anyone? Anyone? Thank you very much for the donation.
Thank you very much, Reuben Reuben.
So, yes, um
He's saying we didn't take any money, but it's like you understand
Reddit could never validate whether or not you've taken money
or whether or not you're behind the scam. It's just that if you're
pushing a scam as the head moderator of a subreddit,
you're going to get you're They they have to do something, right?
Like there's just really I don't know that there's anything else
that you could do here. You That's why it's incumbent on you
as the person posting this stuff to do your due diligence yourself,
right?
Like you have to. The first obvious thing that came to mind was
how do we get their content on the subreddit? Either some super
fans or some editors could clip some cool hype moment from the
show and then post it to the subreddit. But I also had a stretch
goal. And that was what if LSF could be part of the show in some
way? I don't
Here, I'm pulling this back a little bit. I just want to listen
to that whole thing again and make sure I'm not missing anything
about how he first got approached. streamer agency that represents
hundreds of live streamers. I heard about the game show a few
hours after it got announced by a couple major live streamers.
It sounded like the perfect type of content for Live Stream Fail.
I mean, reality TV, game show, live streaming, gaming,
you know, that's perfect for LSF, which is about fun crazy content
about kind of live streaming gamers. So when I heard about this,
I was very excited. I immediately reached out to the organizers
to see if we could set up some sort of a Oh, that's brutal. Okay,
that's brutal. So, from what I originally thought, what I thought
Stail told me originally was that he reached out to or sorry,
Mythic Talent reached out to him.
I'm hearing that basically
Mythic Talent reached out to the creators, the creators promoted
it, and then he reached out to the organizers. Now, him reaching
out to the organizers, I understand how he thinks, well, I There's
a lot of social proof happening here. How could I have But dude,
you are a you are an independent entity that reached out, looked
at this website, and thought nothing of partnering with them.
That's brutal, man. That's
Okay? That's tough, dude. collaboration. This collaboration would
just be to get cool content Yeah, well, he he just said this.
He just said I reached out to them about the collaboration. >> subreddit.
No, you know, financial incentives, no moderators being paid,
basically none of anything like that, just fun cool stuff for
the community in the subreddit. For collaborations, the first
obvious thing that came to mind was how do we get their content
on the subreddit? Either some super fans or some editors could
clip some cool hype moment from the show and then post it to
the subreddit. But I also had a stretch goal. And that was what
if LSF could be part of the show in some way? I don't know. There
could be like a LSF-themed best clip contest. Like contestants
compete in one of the kind of small challenges to make the best
clip and then somebody kind of wins a prize at the end. It was
a stretch goal though. So I reached out to the organizers and
to my surprise, they immediately understood what LSF was, what
power it had, and they even agreed This is agree to the stretch
goal of like the cool competition to have in the actual show.
From my perspective, this felt like one of the coolest things
that a subreddit has ever done. I mean,
Dude, he literally got scammed. This is
I didn't know it was this bad. I didn't get a chance to watch
the video last night. I was already gone to bed.
This is rough. I Dude, it's kind of brutal. Like that Unfortunately
for Stail, and I understand I understand a little bit of wanting
something to be true, right? You want to be true You want it
to be true that people really like LSF. They think it's really
important and that this Amazon show that's going to have a $20
million prize would want to include LSF and integrate it into
the show directly, right? But just think about it. That is insane.
They have enough money, they have enough production value that
they get They have enough, you know, they have a production company,
they're going to make a show that goes on Amazon Prime. They have
a $20 million prize. People who have that wouldn't want to integrate
LSF into the show.
They They wouldn't.
That wouldn't be a thing.
Again, I I hate to say it, but like AOC be getting tons of traffic
that LSF don't. Okay?
It's not that important. It >> It's so rough cuz that That's
exactly how you get scammed, by the way, is you need something
that can't really be given to you in a real way. You need something
badly. It's how you It's why people go to like senior citizens
to scam them. It's why like health care scams work. People have
like a need and it can't be met by reality. And so it's just
It leaves them all to be preyed on by scams. It's [__]
up. I mean, being in a freaking reality TV show in a talk So,
there is a Yes, there is an important question here, Evil Johnny
Bravo, that another thing that would be a good way So, a question
we'll have to ask Stail is, hey Stail, when you when they agreed
to have you in the show, they definitely would have gone and
said something along the lines of, we need assurances on how
stuff's going to be presented, we need like moderation assurances,
right? If they did none of this, if there was nothing attached
in terms of what would be moderated for then I I again don't
believe that anybody would want to get involved with
Yeah, so desperate to get traffic to LSF again, he fell for a
scam. I believe it do be like that though. It do be like that,
Mr. Stail. >> it directly related to the subreddit, how
awesome. And then, you know, maybe I could leverage this to get
even more opportunities either for our subreddit or for other
subreddits across the entire platform. That's how I felt at least,
and that's clearly not how it worked out. After they agreed to
kind of a couple of these kind of requests that I had in my stretch
goal, they immediately started moving very quickly. They, you
know, we wrote up an announcement and they wanted this out within
like 24 hours. So we quickly worked to make an announcement together
and I posted it the next day. When I posted it, everybody in
the comment section immediately yelled scam scam scam scam scam.
This initially didn't actually worry me because no matter what
we do, people call it a scam. I mean, I've done AMAs with the
Twitch CEO, people called that a scam. And I was also That's
not a good answer, again.
That's not a good answer, man. >> multiple major live streamers
were involved, Mythic Talent was involved, surely they had done
their due diligence, right? Again, this is So, he's totally
he's totally seated like his own agency to these other entities,
right? Which you can't do. You are the you are the head mod,
you're the person who leads the subreddit. You cannot say, well,
these other agencies, these other people would have done their
due diligence, right? Nope. Nope. That's on you, man. That's
totally on you. You had to do your own due diligence here. And
I do not believe he would look at that website, look through
all the stuff in the same way that that Charlie did.
I Dude, I don't believe he would do that and then
come to the conclusion that it's not a scam or come to the conclusion
that nothing was wrong here, okay? >> Additionally, the
thing that people were the most skeptical about was the $20 million
grand prize. This initially confused me as well, but once I heard
that, you know, Amazon Prime was allegedly involved, my initial
concerns were assuaged. I mean, think about it. Amazon Prime
has spent lots of money on tons of shows and, you know, I didn't
necessarily think that the show was worth $20 million, but you
know, that doesn't mean that Amazon Prime wouldn't fund it. And
you know, if LSF involved was involved
brutal. Again, brutal. Maybe it would actually succeed. You know,
maybe my involvement alone could make the the $20 million kind
of investment worth it. Who knows? At least that's what I thought.
Now here comes the next part of the
Uh just very a very diluted, okay? Very >> things get a
little crazy. The next day, a major live streamer who was involved
in the show, ExtraEmily, said on her stream that she kind of
saw all of these comments about people calling it a scam and
they even saw that you know, if LSF was involved and this was
apparently uh unacceptable to her. So much so that she was considering
kind of dropping out of the show. The show is fine. I just don't
want to be attached to LSF. That's >> or kind of looking
into see seeing if kind of the whole thing was a scam or not.
After seeing this, I brought the concerns to the organizers and
the organizers told me that they were currently in talks with
the agents to resolve this. And they told me in no certain uncertain
terms that the show was not canceled and was still going on.
So, me being somebody who didn't really have a lot of, you know,
information into the situation and me, you know, trusting these
high-powered agents who is who represent these multi-million
dollar kind of celebrities, I trusted that they would kind of
get to the bottom of this and kind of resolve these concerns
quickly. During this time period, I saw and deleted a lot of
unsubstantiated claims about the show and the mod team. There
were Oh, no.
No, he swept. No, Stail, please. Don't talk about the sweeping.
Don't talk about the sweeping.
Who is this guy? This guy is the former head of reddit.com/r/livestreamfail.
Big clipping big clipping subreddit, okay? That used to get a
ton of traffic. It still gets a decent amount of traffic, but
it's far it's like diminished from where it was. And he would
has been removed for promoting like a scam on the subreddit directly,
okay? And now he's talking about how he's deleting unsubstantiated
clips or sorry, unsubstantiated comments about it being a scam
most likely. So, oh boy. We'll see we'll see what's >> accusations
that I knew to be untrue such that, you know, the mod team had
accepted bribes or, you know, had some sort of financial involvement
with the show and I knew that they were not true because I was
the one who had this this idea the entire time, you know, from
start to finish. This happened a couple days and what I can tell
you for those who, you know, may not believe that for most moderators,
I'm a highly paid software engineer working in San Francisco.
I do not need to take a couple thousand dollar bribes from, you
[clears throat] know, random internet scams, okay?
That's not the issue here and I I think it's it's kind of unfortunate
that he thinks that's the issue.
That's not the issue. His personal whether or not he was personally
enriched by this is absolutely like immaterial to him being removed
as the head of LSF. Uh no, I think it was a different Yura Cozer
and I by the way, I didn't like campaign for any of that just
to be clear. I people voted for me.
I was like running a campaign for that show, okay? I was doing
this because I legitimately, you know, care about the subreddit
and that's why I spend my time on it. I thought it'd be kind
of cool events for the for the sub. I'm talking about this in
kind of the deleted comments because this is apparently some
big no-no in the Reddit TOS or something or maybe it's like an
unspoken rule where if you're involved in some sort of promotion
and it ends up not working out or ends up being kind of a scam
or something, you know, if you have deleted comments that have
accused it of being a scam, well well that, you know, shows a
cover-up or some way. It shows malice or bad faith or something.
So that's why I'm going to talk you about this is cuz this was
specifically a reason that was brought up regarding why I was
kicked out as a mod on the on uh LivestreamFail. And finally,
I want to end this part of the story by talking about how MoistCr1TiKaL
made a video critical of the situation and then about 30 minutes
after this kind of video got released, uh I got reached out by
the organizers of the events and told that five uh live streamers
in the event had dropped out and that therefore the event was
canceled and I should take down the post. In this video that
MoistCr1TiKaL had that was critical of the event, uh MoistCr1TiKaL
brought up points about how an image on the marketing page was
AI generated or that the domain name was registered in Iceland
or that basically just the the whole thing uh it it's it's smelled
it smelled bad. That's what he did. He did this this motion and
he said it smelled bad. But beyond that, it doesn't seem like
he did much research. I don't think that he reached out to any
of the organizers. He certainly didn't reach out to me and I
mean, I don't know if he reached out to Mythic Talent.
This is this is tough cuz he's only commenting on the first Moist
video,
And I do think there's enough there in the first Moist video
to basically
yeah, in my opinion, there's enough there in the first Moist
video to get the whole idea that like it's probably a scam, but
once the second Moist video comes out,
once the second video comes out, he's talking about getting like
the agreement offers and talking like actually reaching out and
talking to these people. I don't think this is true.
I don't think this is broadly like when he makes this video,
this comment on like this is how the Moist stuff maybe it's just
running the timeline,
but I think there's enough there that if you do your due diligence,
you don't partner with that company. So he Stail can say you
didn't conclusively prove it's a scam, but I do think you can
conclusively take away from the website that these aren't people
that you should be partnering with, that there's not enough there
to say, "Okay, I'm going to put my my subreddit, you know, our
good name, the our LSF name, our integrity on the
It's he's definitely he's he's denigrating like the Moist video
in a way that doesn't make sense. >> of the streamers.
Now, I want to stop people here cuz this is very important and
I think this is something that not a lot of people might have
noticed. And that important point is that nothing in this situation
has yet to be definitively proven as a scam. I repeat, there
is no definitive, at least public information yet that anything
fraudulent, malicious, or illegal has happened in the situation.
The
that can't be the bar. That that is an insane
I'm sorry, that is an insane like bar, okay?
So, if you guys have been following the Turkey Tom situation,
Nicholas DeOrio decided that he was going to put Half-Baked,
his podcast with Tom, on hiatus until they could figure out what
was going on, right? The appearance of impropriety is enough
for people of
high repute, I guess, you'd say high repute, to move away. That
when you look at something, there's the appearance of impropriety
here, it's hard to look at it otherwise, right? You don't have
to be able to prove conclusively it's a scam to say you shouldn't
be involved and that it looks shady enough that I question like
your bonafides if you're going to try to partner with them. These
are like totally different This is sort of a subtle This is sort
of a debate debate pervertory thing where you're like you're
going to say, "Well, what if I It's not something proven to be
a scam. What am I supposed to leave comments up when it's not
conclusively proven as a scam?"
No, that's not what anyone's saying. It's like this looks really
shady.
And it it obviously does. It obviously has from the very beginning.
It looks so shady, okay? You can't You can't just say, "Okay,
well, but it's not proven to be illegal yet." Yeah, but that's
going to come later. If if it comes, it's going to come later.
You're putting your sub's reputation on the line with the like
the shadiest looking >> things that we have right now is
that I guess there was a website looked a little weird, there
were some bad publicity, everybody called it a scam, and then
a bunch of streamers dropped out, and then the event got canceled,
and everybody got refunded. None of this is illegal. None of
this is proven to be a scam, at least yet. Maybe I'll eat these
words. And yes, in retrospect, there are certainly some things
which we
It's not Yeah, that that's not the bar. So he's fighting with
like a straw man here. That's not the bar. Proving it illegal
is not the >> yellow flags or even red flags. But that
being said, I don't want people to go into this thinking that
there were some proven malfeasance or something uh when it there
really is
Well, I guess that defeats the idea that it is, you know, AI
scripted. I don't think I don't think any AI is going to use
the word malfeasance, all right?
yeah, again, he's presenting like this false bar for like where
he should be, you know, punished or removed from the
There's he's like presenting some false bar here. I don't think
that's the bar. To me, the bar is you as the head of this subreddit
decided to partner with something that seems pretty clearly fake
or questionable
and people were getting charged, had paid through this website
to buy entries into this contest that, you know, you would every
reason to suspect might not be happening.
If you look through it, if you did any due diligence, you probably
would have come to this conclusion.
I really don't think it has to go any further than that, that
like you've just shown yourself to be kind of incompetent as
the leader of the site.
And you being removed, like it does look
basically there's the appearance of impropriety here, right?
So, the material reality of whether or not you took money won't
matter. They'll remove people who have who could have taken money,
basically, in this situation. If you do promote something that
turns out to be a scam, they'll remove you because they'll never
really be able to unless it goes to some huge legal thing, they'll
never even be able to prove that you took money, right?
Unless you're like totally they'll never ever be able to prove
you took money from this. You have infinite plausible deniability.
So, the bar can't be it has to be proven to be illegal and proven
that you've taken money from it. That's a wild bar that would
never work.
They'd have scam they could leave scamming moderators up everywhere
because they go, "Well, I I didn't know and I didn't take any
money." And then they've no investigative power,
right? So, they have to just go with the appearance of impropriety
and make a >> There's a possibility that a lot of this
could have just been kind of bad organization and things just
fell through. Just because something's a bad idea, just because
something is disorganized, that doesn't mean that anything illegal
happened. You know, I still haven't gotten confirmation about
kind of the Amazon Prime kind of a thing. I think that that is
the the biggest unknown right now is I don't know about this
supposed Amazon Prime deal if it exists or not because maybe
they were in negotiation with them, maybe a contract was in the
works, but it hadn't been signed yet. I'm not really sure yet.
We'll have to see. And then kind of I'll end the story by talking
about why I got removed as the top moderator. It's really not
the secret or very surprising. I got removed directly for the
post that I pinned to the top of the subreddit related to the
the game show or supposed and alleged scam, as well as kind of
for deleting comments that were kind of critical of it. I also
want to make a comment about kind of the Reddit Code of Conduct
team as a whole. Reddit has all this flowery language about how
kind of the Code of Conduct team is not here to punish you. It's
kind of here to get you to act in good faith. It's here to kind
of give you second chances and warnings and all of this stuff.
And apparently apparently all of that are lies because I was
not given any second chances. I was not given very many very
much kind of
examples of kind of what I did wrong or kind of given any ability
to kind of defend myself. I was just given a very big description
of yeah, there's accusations about some fraudulent scam that
takes people's money and their PII, which means their their name,
right? Because you have to sign up with your name to join a contest.
And so I have infringed on the Code of Conduct by promoting a
game show where you have to put in your your name or something,
even though it hasn't really been proven to be fraudulent yet.
And so it's just it's a little bit
Oh man, I I don't know how he could possibly think that this
is really where the bar is. I almost I feel like he must know
deep
that that isn't where the bar is, right?
That it's obviously an appearance of >> is the most important
part of the video, Spez. This is a direct message to you and
only you. I want to talk about how this whole situation is a
direct result of the lack of support that Reddit the company
gives to its moderators. Yeah, I did the partnership. Yeah, I
did This should be very interesting, okay? I don't know how he's
going to blame Spez for this, but I am very excited to hear how
you promoting this was actually Spez's fault the whole time.
I I'm super I'm psyched, okay? I'm psyched. I'm grabbing water.
I'm still listening. I can pause if he says anything that I need
to react to. But yes, this is the core piece. What is what is
truth and what is false? >> this as much as I should and
I trusted kind of agencies and live streamers when I should not
have. And I did delete comments, which I thought would have been
borderline defamatory if the situation wasn't I guess it a scam,
even though it technically hasn't been proven to be a scam yet.
But despite all of that, there was still massive kind of like
problems at Reddit the company due to the lack of support that
cost us. But right before I go into the specific reasons of how
this happened, I want to talk about why this matters in the first
place. And this matters because Reddit moderators have power.
They have influence. If you were one of the people who is joking
about like internet janitor duties or whatever, I'm sorry to
tell you, it's funny jokes, but you are wrong. Reddit moderation
does matter. Reddit moderators have control over millions of
impressions per day and nobody seems to notice or care. Let's
just talk about LSF. Think of all the streamer careers that have
been created because of LSF. Think about the even larger number
of streamer careers that have been just So okay. He's talking
about this. This is like kind of true, okay? This is kind of
true about Reddit moderators do control millions of impressions
and I'm not even going to mock him for it, okay? I I understand
where he's coming
It's infinitely mockable, okay? It's infinitely mockable. Shut
up, poker boy. It's infinitely mockable and I understand that.
All right. That but here's the thing.
While that could be true,
ultimately the reason those impressions are important, the reason
stuff like that's important is because like you should be able
to monetize that or something, right? And you're explicitly not
allowed to monetize any of this
Oh, Evil Johnny Bravo, you got a theory,
That's like I do think it's true that they control impressions
and there is some power to the job, but ultimately it's like
if you start really influencing things in a direction, you're
going to get removed, right? Here's the thing, you literally
just got removed for influencing things in a direction, for trying
to use your power to do something untoward, for for doing something
bad, right? So you will get removed if you're clearly directing
things, if you're clearly trying to bias the subreddit, if you're
clearly trying to influence things. I do believe you will get
removed. As we see here, obviously he's been removed,
It's sort of like saying politicians have power, so actually
like you should respect them because they have power. Well, it's
true, it's like they are they are beholden to the people. There's
a limit to what they can do with that power. They can't just
overtly like control things, okay? In a democracy at
Like they do have power. This is true, but it's only on the edges
where they can be swayed. They can't just overtly be corrupt.
And so that power has like limits and checks and it can only
be wielded in certain ways. It's very it's very different from
like the power fantasy that we were hearing about here. It's
bizarre to me.
day and nobody seems to notice or care. Let's just talk about
LSF. Think of all the streamer careers that have been created
because of LSF. Think about the even larger number of streamer
careers that have been destroyed because of LSF, because some
clip went viral about like something bad that they did. I had
had major live streamers who were effectively celebrities come
to me and beg to kind of remove, you know, negative posts about
them. An even crazier story is the time when some Twitch employees
found me in person and borderline begged me to make sure LSF
is not used to destroy the multi-billion dollar company Twitch,
partially because at the time LSF Yeah. Okay. That's uh possibly
true. And I believe as well that that's why he took all of this,
okay? Was that that was the power he sought. He wanted this all,
right? Uh I understand that. Hold on. was indeed being used to
destroy the multi-billion dollar company Twitch. Deservedly so,
by the way. Or even just
So he says it has the power to destroy. It's like Well, that's
not really true.
People people have the power to like build narratives on LSF
and they
they all can control it a little bit.
I think when people do that, there's a limit to what Spez can
do to help them, right? Spez can't just remove stuff. If Spez
was overtly just removing everything negative about streamers
all the time with no rule set and no possible like plausible
deniability for why he was doing it, then he would start to get
in trouble, as he did when he was removing stuff around I think
it was the the Erobb stuff, the there was some extra Emily thing
that she was getting heat for. Was it her comments on her like
wealth? Her comments on like how she wouldn't pay her parents
back? I think there was some janny-ing there that happened that
probably shouldn't have,
And I do think you start to build up like negative like sort
of antipathy towards you in the LSF user base. So I I don't know.
It's it's just again, he thinks it has this power. People perceive
that power. It's not really power for him to change the direction
or the flow of impressions and all of this.
or at least as it becomes more overt, he's more likely to be
overthrown.
Right? It's very much people are comparing it to being like school
council president. It's very much like that, yes. You can't just
do whatever you want. >> just take this literal circumstance.
Imagine the whole kind of operation was legit. Well, guess what?
One single post on LSF caused all of the streamers to drop out
and destroyed a $20 million
Sorry, Mythic. My bad. Or there's no way there's no way there's
no way, man.
There's no way. >> One single post on LSF caused all of
the streamers to drop out and destroyed a $20 million opportunity.
Sorry, Mythic. My bad. Or imagine it was Why is he running this
hypothetical, man? You look so goofy as running this hypothetical.
>> a I guess a scam through and through. Well, guess what?
We were the ones to expose it and destroy it before it had the
chance to cause any real harm. I mean, everybody got refunded
after all. Guess things ended up okay. Right or wrong, you can
think I'm a good moderator or a bad moderator. You can think
that LSF helps streamers or is the bane of their existence in
the entire industry. But please, don't for a single second pretend
like it doesn't matter. And that's just
So here you'd have to litigate exactly what was removed and I
don't know. But I'm guessing that there were posts accusing you
of being a scam that got removed, that got janny-ed, that got
swept up. And that also that that does go it cuts against like
he literally kind of gave it away. I assume those exist because
apparently Reddit gave this to him as a reason for why he was
being removed. His comments on it being a scam were removed,
right? So I do think I do think the fact
that he said that second point, like we helped expose it, I I
think you were working directly against that and that's their
reasoning for removing you.
He's blowing kisses. Weird. >> the entire industry. Weird.
You guys are weird. Okay, let's back it up and listen to that
again. Things ended up okay. Right or wrong, you can think I'm
a good moderator or a bad moderator. You can think that LSF helps
streamers or is the bane of their existence in the entire industry.
But please, don't for a single second pretend like it doesn't
matter. And that's just one subreddit. Now back to me. I was
one of your most passionate users. I was in the Reddit partnership
program from the start. I took advantage of every opportunity
that I could. I had meetings with kind of the Reddit community
community managers. I begged them for help and kind of partnership
opportunities at every chance that I could. And I was blown off
every single time. I got nothing out of it. The community managers
never helped me. As, you know, nice as the guy I was, I think
he had basically no power to help me. I was one of the only moderators
out there who tried to grow my community, who had any ambition,
who tried to work with the company or help other subreddits or
help the kind of the company as a whole, and it didn't matter.
I failed and it failed because of how mismanaged and how little
support Reddit the company gives to moderators. So let's circle
back.
Oh man, did I miss
I'm trying to look into these deleted
Oh, I'm dude, I I'm trying to think cuz he seemed to be blaming
the the fact that the scam was promoted, right? Is that what
he's he's saying in my desperation, because Reddit wouldn't give
me the tools to build my subreddit. In my desperation, I turned
to a man I didn't fully understand, some Indian man from Canada.
Is that is that what he's saying here? Okay. I I I do believe
that's the
the impression I'm I'm getting. Is he saying because because
Reddit couldn't help me, give me the tools to fix my problems.
I was forced to turn to a man who was a scammer, okay?
God, I
That's just it's too far, man. I don't >> Let's go back
to the moderation situation. This is a very key important point,
so please pay attention. None of this would have happened if
I had gotten support from Reddit. Do you think that I want to
be the guy like going out like messaging random people in Discords
and LinkedIns and trying to figure out kind of these partnerships?
I don't
Who's this guy messaging Who's this guy messaging on LinkedIn?
What the [__] >> is not my job. I am not qualified
to do any of this. I am not a lawyer. I do not like I cannot
read contracts to know what I should do or I should not do. I
just want to like grow my subreddit, have a big vision, and I
don't want to do this. At the end of the day
boy oh boy >> Reuben Reuben donated $3.
Who told him to redeem? a random nobody who got lucky. I took
over one of your largest gaming subreddits on the platform because
I won a stupid game of like Reddit mod politics. But apparently,
I'm the only person out there who understands the potential that
Reddit has. If Reddit had offered me partnerships, if Reddit
had pipelines to connect with kind of major companies, if Reddit
had lawyers that were helping me like reading over these contracts,
reading over these agreements, none of these very real mistakes
that I made would have happened. And before you say it, I'm sure
there's some employee at Reddit the company
Bro, I I don't like this. Again, he's he's really absolving himself
of blame here, and I think
Bro, does anybody have the clip? Where's the clip of Dan going
off on Extra Emily, okay? Can we play this for Stale right now?
live stream fail
Dan Extra Emily
I didn't watch it, but I do know Oh, yeah, Extra Emily totally
like backs it I'm like, I'm just doing what I'm supposed to do,
okay? So, I don't know what's happening, but >> No, that's
Hold on. Pause. You don't get to say that. You don't get to say,
"I'm just doing what I'm supposed to do, okay?" You
are repped by an agency, and the agency said, "Hey, you're going
to do a show. You're going to be part of this show. It's called
the Million Dollar Fan." Uh and you if you're too stupid to go
and do the research and find out what you're promoting, that's
on you, but you don't get to blame it be like, "Oh, sorry, guys.
I just station
By the way, I would actually give Emily the out here on this
one a little bit cuz Emily is paying that agency to do the due
diligence, right? But Stale doesn't have this excuse. So, what
Dan is saying here applies like 10x to >> without uh thinking
anything. Well, you could say that. You could say that you're
a [__] [__] and you just agreed to [__]
from your agency without doing it, but you signed on to be a
part of whatever the [__] this is, and then people
saw that, "Oh, Extra Emily is a part of this [__]
This would be really good content for LSF. Uh let's do something
here." You don't get to be like, "Oh, wait, but I don't know
what
Ain't no way. Stale got to Dan. You hear Dan? Dan's parroting
some opinions here,
Dan's parroting some opinions. Oh, and and even LSF, they they
took you seriously, and now it's your fault. No.
No. No, what it is now that people are saying it's a scam. How
many other [__] have you done [clears throat] that
you have no idea what the [__] is going on? Like,
come on. >> Dan Dan versus the English language is just
a fantastic thing to watch sometimes, okay? How many other [__]
have you done like this? How many other [__] have
you done? Awesome stuff. Awesome stuff, Dan. Okay. All right.
So, I do think that applies 10x to Stale. I don't think Stale
gets to use the the comment. It sounds like Stale might have
talked to Dan, but I don't think you get to use the commentary,
okay? Well, actually, Extra Emily supported this, and she's backed
by Mythic, so I get to No. No, man. You're not You're not >> like,
"Oh, yeah, we do we do do that. That's that's my job. It's over
here." Well, clearly, you're not even doing 1% of what you should
be doing because nobody uses these resources, nobody cares, you
are not doing enough. Multiply it by 100, and then let's talk.
Reddit needs to be professionalized, and it starts with the mods.
This is going to be controversial, but the people who are running
your multi-billion website are unqualified nobodies like me.
That doesn't mean it's my fault or their fault. It's your fault,
Spaz. Here's why. The controversial solution is uh just get rid
of the the bad mods with better mods or paid mods or do takeovers
or more rules or something like that. But there are better solutions.
You can train them. You can give mods infrastructure or pipelines
or resources or real kind of material support and treat them
as if they have the actual power and influence that they actually
have, and so communities can rise to the heights they truly could.
And the Reddit moderator partner program is not it. Reddit moderators
do not need one call with like one guy a month, as nice as he
is. Love you, Pablo. Who has no power and no ability to affect
anything. Reddit moderators don't need Christmas celebrations
or special badges or community or events or team-building exercises.
No, even the
So, this is really funny in that like Reddit does try to make
it so those communities build up themselves. Stale's like trying
to create like some
some like ha how do I even explain it? Stale's like trying to
create like a media empire or something with LSF. Like he's trying
to create something where LSF is like its own thing. If you really
wanted this, just go to somewhere that's like not affiliated
to
Reddit. Like Reddit Reddit isn't about that. Reddit's supposed
to be about like communities like niche communities where you
build these things up, and it's like just about that topic or
whatever. It's not about partnering with companies. It's not
about all this other [__] You're You're doing something
that like is not supposed to be what Reddit is. Reddit was never
built to be that like corporate like we're going to feed corporate
opportunities through here. I don't know. I get where Stale's
coming from like a little bit.
But I just don't I don't It seems like it's explicit in their
TOS that they don't want the kind of [__] like this
They They kind of just want you guys to manage the community,
manage the comments. I feel like DGG hyped up a clearly stupid
idea.
This one? I don't think they're they're not behind like the the
game show or something, are they? That would be
Yeah. I Anyway, I think I think he built something outside of
LSF or I don't know start directing traffic to something else
cuz like LSF it feels like just wasn't going to be because of
the Reddit terms of service. Just wasn't going And what what
Reddit saw is what moderators should be doing. Right? Cuz ultimately,
here's another thing that's really important. Reddit doesn't
want to give away those impressions for free, right? That That's
something they can monetize. That's their resource. They're not
going to say, "Okay, we're going to give you the tools to like
build that out and monetize it yourself or set up these opportunities."
There's nothing they don't want that, right? They don't want
any of that. If they want to monetize that, that's their resource
that they'll monetize. If they want to let other people monetize
it. If they want to let other people take advantage of it. If
they think the most important thing is getting other people to
come to Reddit and do collabs there, then they'll set up those
resources. They clearly didn't think LSF was a priority. And
the I I I think they have had thought other Sorry, they have
thought that other subreddits were a priority. The AMA subreddit,
I think, gets this kind of support where they do these like collaborations,
where they do actually reach out to people. They do have connections.
But I think that's unique. I don't think they see LSF as that
thing.
And they get to decide ultimately. It seems like they've pretty
explicitly said, "No, no, no, we don't We don't want to support
that. We're not doing that." But I don't >> I know that
the Reddit event budget is barely useful. No, they need real
material support. That means access to anything that like a talent
manager would give an actual celebrity. So, an access to a bounty
board or ad deals or lawyers or event organizers or professionals
or anything that actually matters. To summarize, Reddit moderators
should be treated like celebrities or influencers, not because
No shot. No shot. Bro, come on, man. You can't be throwing out
lines like this. This Is this just rage bait? Is this just pure
rage bait? Has Stale been doing this character just to get yelled
at? Does he just like getting yelled at? That's a crazy line
to throw in the video, dude.
That's an insane line to throw in the video. Actually, they shouldn't
be celebrities. They should be the opposite. They should be like
faceless people who are just concerned with the minutia of making
sure the sub functions correctly. That's it. That's it. That's
all they should be. That's all Reddit wants them to be. That
is it. Like faceless drones. THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO BE.
an actual celebrity. So, an access to a bounty board or ad deals
or lawyers or event organizers or professionals or anything that
actually matters. To summarize, By the way, I think because of
my reaction to this, I'm not sure if I'm I'm not sure if Stale's
going to come on. We'll see. I don't I don't know if he's going
to come on. This is
He hasn't said anything. He just stopped responding to me. And
I'm like I'm I'm hoping he's not watching and like getting really
If you want to argue any of the points I'm making, by the way,
I'm totally fine with arguing them. Uh Myra, thank you for the
five gifted. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. But like I can't just
lie. It Dude, this is bad. This is bad. This video is bad, and
your conduct that led up to this was bad. And I'm cool to talk
through it, and you can make your arguments back in the other
direction, but it seems pretty clear to me that the conduct here
is just bad on its face.
And if you want to change my mind, by the way, I'm totally open
to having my mind changed.
Completely open. To summarize, Reddit moderators should be treated
like celebrities or influencers, not because they deserve respect
or anything, but because they actually have real power and influence.
I mean, if not for the world, at least over your $50 company.
Maybe if you gave them actual support, it could go from 50 billion
to 100 billion. I mean, it certainly deserves to be that high
up for how much traffic Reddit gets. So, why haven't you solved
this problem already, Spaz? Is it because you're out of touch
and you aren't aware of the problem? Is it because Reddit is
a bloated mess, and they can't ship products? No, I think the
real issue is that Reddit is held hostage by the negativity and
toxicity of its user base, and it it doesn't really have the
freedom to make bold and important and transformative decisions
that could save the company. If you agree with anything that
I said, Spaz,
No, no, Stale might be coming on. >> you're in luck. I
live in San Francisco, and I would be happy to talk to employee
at all, you know, or on a call or something. That's my pitch
to you, Spez. The rest is to the community. To the community,
Spez and Reddit, they're almost certainly not going to fix any
of this. All of this is up to us to solve. For anyone who this
message has resonated with and wants to solve this problem, well,
I have created a subreddit called r/suballiance.
Suballiance will be a nonprofit volunteer community-based initiative
to solve all the problems that I have laid out. We will create
tools and resources so good, so useful that everybody will have
to work with us. Think talent agency, but for subreddits. You
have the big ideas, you have the vision, you have the crazy cool
thing
There's no way. Wait, CheeseBeef, you're not involved in CX,
are you? Are you like You're not Ice's number one moderator or
something, are you? I feel like I've seen you in there. This
This kind of thing makes you reevaluate whether watching two
Watching streams is too much of a loser activity to do. Well,
well, why is his mouth so wet? He's got an AI filter on.
Listen, I
I'd say wanting the approval of streamers so badly Oh, I just
thought I thought you're somebody from CX. I just recognized
you from CX. Nothing, never mind. I I thought you were like super
involved in Ice's community, which just made the comment funny
and ironic, but I think you were intending that. So,
yeah, I
This is too much. This is too parasocial. This is too much like
getting involved. You just want to be on the team. You just want
to be on the team so
And I just don't think anybody wants that, man.
You got DGear of the Year somehow? No, no, no, no, no, he didn't
get DGear of the Year. He did not. Maybe it was during one of
Ice's crash outs. Maybe you were feeling one of Ice's crash outs.
Probably. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's probably what it was. Jesus,
dude.
This video is rough. Apparently, he's doing an interview though,
so he wasn't watching my reaction, which is perfect, cuz I That
could only have gone badly, all right? We've got a little bit
more to add to this. We do have Hassan watching this video. We've
got actually a couple
We got a couple other things. So, we'll We're going to go through
We're going to check it out. you want to do, and we handle the
logistics. Materially, that means connections to major companies,
partnerships, doing AMAs, running events, doing mod recruitment,
cross-collaboration with other relevant subreddits, that kind
of stuff. Go to
and we will make it happen. The link will be in the description
below. Reddit used to be a place where we did stuff. The phrase,
"We did it, Reddit," although used sarcastically, existed for
a reason. And that is because we What we do, right or wrong,
matters. Let's see what we can do to make it better. Okay. We
did it. We did it, Reddit. Let's go. Absolutely wild. Absolutely
wild.
I don't know, man. I don't know. I don't know, man. I That's
That's a rough video, okay? There's a little bit more content
here. Give me a second. I think we got logs that dropped after
the video came out, and we could do We could do maybe the moist
video. Are we going to do the moist video on this? We take a
look, okay? Apparently, he has some logs that dropped after.
Let's check these out. "Stale2000 is now coping DGear chat following
the negative reception of his video addressing the scam he was
involved in promoting on r/live
claiming the video wasn't meant to be taken literally, and that
he was simply playing it up / being post-ironic."
Bro, there's no shot. No, you weren't. No, you weren't. Come
on, man.
Come on, dude.
I'll give it Maybe I would I could maybe give him the lines,
but the problem is the lines he's saying All of his points, unless
the entire thing is just like, "Oh, yeah, I'm I'm like making
this to to play it up." Like unless all of his points that he
doesn't want to stand on By the way, points he's been making
for like 2 years. He'll go on streams and say, "Reddit doesn't
give us the tools. I want to do more collabs. I want more access
to like Reddit's, you know, resources." He said that for years
now. And now he's like, "Oh, I was only pretending." And all
of the points he's making that are cringe are points he's making
in like furtherance of that idea that I need more resources.
I need more help from Reddit, right?
So, it doesn't make sense that he'd say that this is sarcastic.
Not to me, at least. Need to watch Hassan's because I owe you
an apology? What?
What are you talking about? Well, we'll
Don't watch Moist, watch Hassan. Okay, maybe we'll do We could
do both, but maybe we'll just watch Hassan, okay? Five five-page
wall of text script written. No, I just have to film it. Ba ba
ba ba ba ba ba ba. Well, I did it. Made a 20-minute YouTube video
in 6
People were begging me to see the drama before. The analogies
regarding talent agencies and infrastructure is not meant to
be taken literally. I think the CEO will watch it. Whether or
not the code of conduct team takes cares is a different story,
though. They won't.
We meme in today. By the way, I don't I Sorry. By the way, I
know people think my video is cringe, but the thesis
was simply that Reddit is run by an army of untrained, unqualified
underqualified nobodies like myself, and Reddit needs to do something
about that.
I'm on Dexerto now. Man, I do not know how to make things go
viral. Or sorry, man, do I know how to make things go viral?
Just play into the ultra cringe Reddit mod aesthetic, and people
will lap it up. Uh-huh. Okay. Play into it. Yes, play into it.
What did you think the video was completely serious?
I was obviously being post-ironic. Believe what you are saying,
but lean into it in an over-the-top way. Okay, maybe he's leaning
into it in a slightly over-the-top way. Like maybe those two
lines that are the worst, like Reddit moderators need to be treated
like celebrities, maybe that's something he threw in explicitly,
okay? But he is trying to make the argument that they should
be treated better with like more seriousness, right? Which is
in and of itself funny. I'm sorry, it is already funny in and
of itself. So, no, nothing changes. If anything, you were right,
DGear, I was protecting Hassan, but it wasn't because I care
about Hassan. It was being It was being the political drama was
getting boring, and I wanted new content. Well, not going to
stop that stuff anymore.
Okay. Better than nobody noticing or caring. A Hail Mary's my
only play. There are worse things in this world than looking
like an overly obsessed cringe person who takes what they do
too
I I don't know like I feel like when people just set themselves
on fire and go, "That was intentional," it's just not believable,
right?
If he'd done something else, if he'd
If he had something else going on on the internet, I would believe
it, but it just seems like he set himself on fire repeatedly,
and now he's going, "Yeah, I I meant to. Yeah, I meant to set
myself on fire, 100%. That was what I was going for. Yeah, it's
it's goofy. Anyway, I've got the Hassan
Hassan tweet about Stale and Hassan reacting to Stale. Which
order do they go in? I don't know. Hassan tweeted about Stale.
This was earlier today. This would have been after his stream.
So, we'll watch his stream first.
Tabs to the right. This is the top mod of the subreddit after
promoting scam contest million dollar fan. He has posted a video
demanding
Wait, maybe he posted before. Well, we'll take a look at his
his post, at least, okay? "Destiny's top orbiter who openly turned
LSF into a harassment / cyberstalking operation for enemies of
his favorite streamer has been forcibly removed from his position.
He's still bragging that the entire mod team are his people,
by the way."
Pretty sure the top orbiter position belongs to Mr. Mouton. Not
too sure who this guy is. Okay. All right, I thought Pierces
was going to make a serious comment disagreeing.
I do think that Stale probably did less to promote anti-Hassan
content than people think. I do think so. When was he Is he schizo
when he was stopping Hassan stuff? Didn't he change the rules
so they can upload edited clips?
I don't know what you're talking about. Maybe they changed the
rules. I don't know if he did that or not.
I'm unaware of that, but I don't think I don't think his protection
of like
anybody is Like I I just see it as trying to create
reputation or sorry, positive relationships with all streamers.
I don't think it's like he's taking a side as the mod of LSF.
Except maybe with some of the comments, like I do think the people
who would post about Destiny's drama got banned from like his
like making comment on the subreddit, which seemed a little weird
to me, but whatever. If that's what you want to do, that's I
don't know.
No, he absolutely takes sides. Well, he takes the side of all
streamers it to build a relationship with them, right? To have
positive thoughts, like to be thought of warmly by them. That's
what he does, right?
Yes. Yeah. Dude, it is The positive content thing just doesn't
work. I don't know talking about there.
Anyway, let's watch the Hassan reaction to a little bit of the
video. I Maybe it's just a clip here. Let's see what he's saying.
The full video is 21 minutes long. Hello. Yeah, CheeseBeef, like
I've I've noticed this as well. He has like a very slanted view
on the Pixie lawsuit, it seems like. Like I think he posted in
my Discord about his thoughts on the Pixie lawsuit. I think almost
none of it lined up with reality, if I remember
He's obviously got really close relationships with people in
Destiny's
I just don't I'm trying not to make accusations I can't back
up. That's all. Like obviously, there's some appearance of impropriety
even there, right? A bunch of people are watching it. We have
to talk about this. Okay, this is Stale,
former Twitch staff Stale. He used to work at Twitch. And also,
not only that, oh boy, oh boy, but you know, mega omega Destiny
looking and sounding exactly what you know, exactly how you would
assume a a Reddit moderator, like a perma Reddit moderator, would
look like. Okay, bro, it's such a good performance art piece.
Yeah, so,
here's what happened. Okay.
Looks hotter than I would have expected. Facts. So, this guy
ran and won, I believe, top orbiter of the year inside of DGear.
This is a real
I don't think he did. Did he win? I don't think he won like DGear
of the Year or something, right? they do every year, and I think
he he made a video for it. We found out that he had made a video
for it a while back and he deleted the video and We're talking
about Stale and Stale's application for DG Gear of the Year,
which was interesting.
But basically what happened is uh this
overtook Live Stream Fails a couple of years ago as the top moderator
of Live Stream Fails. Now, if you don't know what Live Stream
Fails is is because I never go on this website.
Uh it's because I never go on that subreddit any longer. It used
to be a subreddit where uh people would gather and and you know
check out the top
uh news stories of the day or you know top clips of the day from
Twitch. It was a place where like a lot of Twitch watchers congregated.
Obviously, there was like a like a heavy slant on harassing certain
villains on the subreddit. Alinity, one of them. Pokimane was
another
>> Dude, every time they're like, "Oh, actually, you know,
there's some real villains out here." Or sorry, not real villains.
Every time LSF is like kind of going in on someone, you hear
like, "Oh, you know, a lot of streamers will frame that as harassment
or them getting like unjustifiably harassed." It's like, "Dude,
Alinity did herself no favors back in the day, okay? Alinity
did herself zero favors. The cat thing, the copyright striking,
you know, let's copy strike this guy on PewDiePie. Bro, she did
her she built that negative reputation herself, okay? Don't take
that away from her. >> consistent one.
The cat thing, by the way, wasn't that bad. People freaked it
way People way overreacted to the cat thing. >> years,
but once they said >> Uh Destiny took over the the entire
in this uh uh forcible takeover.
They turned it directly into the Hasan subreddit and uh oftentimes
they would uh oftentimes Yeah, here this is the DG Gear of the
Year. Oh god, he's going to watch the video. Not great. Not good.
Now, I will say, what year is this? I don't know what year is
2021. Yeah, I wasn't even a DG I didn't even have a DG Gear account
in 2021, so couldn't have been against me. I was just about to
make a point.
Not on the Alinity thing. alpha Hasan subreddit and uh Oh, the
subreddit. I think the element comes from people not really engaging
in Live Stream Fail, right? I do think this was against you No,
it wasn't. It
I don't think I don't think so. The video says it's from 2021.
It wasn't against me. It wasn't anything like I don't think
But anyway, sorry. I'm trying to say Hasan pulls his people out
of these places and then he's shocked they turn into like places
that totally despise him. You can't You can't not engage. Not
engaging is not an option, okay? Hasan needs to be militant.
Hasan needs to say, "If you If you clip my [__] and
if you explain how these people are lying, I'm going to cover
you. I'm going to cover you. I'm going to retweet your [__]
I'm going to like your shit." Hasan has to be militant, okay?
You are building an army and you have two options. You either
build an army or you get run over, okay? Everyone else building
army out here, okay? Everyone else is building up armies of clippers,
armies of people who are engaged. Don't do the "Oh, it's really
loser behavior to go and engage with this stuff." Don't do that.
That's the opposite of what you should be doing, okay? Tell people
to engage. Support them engaging. Try to do it in a way that
doesn't seem totally deranged, but you do need to actually engage.
You do need to actually be a part of it cuz saying it's like
bad and and trying to get everybody out of it not a good play,
okay? You'll get run >> Oftentimes they would Oftentimes
Yeah, here this is the DG Gear of the Year. I don't know why
we can't actually watch the video. >> Hi, I'm Stale 2000
and I'm running for DG Gear of the Year on December the 3rd.
In this video I published I'm going to be talking about how all
of my opponents are way worse than me using facts, logic, and
most importantly, evidence as in chat logs. Here, Albert FCB
is asking people to gift him subs. A real DG Gear buys his own
subs. In the month of November, Fitz spammed the Miano hype emote
over 500 times. They're clearly a weeb. Need I say more? Based
on the
No, that person is a Stale, thank you for calling them out as
a in your video directly. I appreciate you, Stale, for calling
that out. Thank you. >> frequency of messages between Bojack
Horseman and Majestic Gopher, who is another candidate in this
election, we can see that these two candidates are clearly colluding
and are therefore disqualified. From these logs, we can see that
Keen is clearly too busy with his girlfriend, as well as worse,
his real friends, to be DG Gear of the Year. Everybody knows
that a DG Gear's only true friend is Destiny. Other DG analysts
suggest that Majestic Gopher would be the best candidate to win
the election because he averages 300 messages a day. But as mentioned
previously, he was colluding and these numbers are clearly Are
all those names still in DG Gear? I would guess that the really
involved people clearly fake. Rayd Why is unethically supporting
NFT projects. A true DG Gear should know that the only ethical
NFT project is those offered by our lovely sponsors at eternal.gg
where you can buy and sell Destiny's personal NFTs. The DJ suggests
that the jury of the Rittenhouse trial should not talk about
the case while it's in recess. But how is the jury supposed to
know what to think if they haven't heard Destiny's opinion on
the matter? As we all know, Destiny has the food pallet of a
10-year-old and a 10-year-old would love to have mac and cheese
at Thanksgiving, but Tony disagrees. Therefore, he's in contradiction
with Destiny and does not deserve to win this
Uh Hasan Hasan just knows Hasan, by the way, doesn't even care
about this video. Hasan just knows that playing this is like
better than any commentary he could provide. Playing it with
no commentary is the best attack on Destiny's community that
he can do. He's just going to sit back and be like, "Look at
this. Hey, look at this." Hasan just showed up to show and tell,
okay? And the best part is he's not even going to cheer react
to it. He's going to sit here and he's going to smirk the entire
time. Okay? What a up thing. competition Ufu complains about
running into alt-righters in a video game. A would have defeated
those alt-righters in the marketplace of ideas and in the video
game. >> Fault violated my boundary of running against
me for of the Year. Therefore, he must lose to satisfy my boundary.
Virgil suggests that Destiny could be inconsistent on anything.
A deserving would know that Destiny is always consistent on all
his positions. Will Kill Forever admits to having a job. No truly
dedicated could work a job Hold on. Hold on. I need to do I need
to run through my requests real quick, okay? Hasan is bad. Hasan
is bad. Jesus Christ. It sounds weird when I do it multiple times
in a row. All right. Are those are knocked out? The next I'll
do the batch again in like 30 minutes or something, okay? Thank
you very much. and dedicate themselves enough to be deserving
of winning this
You got to sometimes see the ops, you know? Sometimes you got
to take a look good hard look at the ops, okay?
Lucky for us, some of our ops openly post videos of themselves
on the internet. No, this is not satire. This is a person who
is in the that is actively trying to win this award as the greatest
cult member for that year. I forget which year this is.
But the point The reason why I'm showing you all of this is because
this is the
at the direction and at the behest of Destiny in order to serve
his master. If this is what your average jerk contestant look
like, imagine the actual winner of this contest. Can we get a
list of all
I didn't collect I Sorry, I didn't campaign for that. I basically
told people I don't care. I don't want you to vote. I don't care.
I don't care. I don't care. People voted for me. I didn't ask
them to vote for me, okay? I didn't do this. I didn't run some
campaign going, "Oh, go vote for me." I'm like, "Get Get the
[__] out of here. I don't care. Get the [__]
out of here."
took over Live Stream Fails and turned it into a smear machine,
okay? For not only myself, but all of Destiny's ops. Now, back
in the day he used to be a fan of mine as well. And even up until
2024, he was in the chat, too. He said, "No, I prefer renting.
I just want to be able to move wherever I want. I don't want
all that money in one asset."
Okay? But somewhere along the line, somewhere along this long
convoluted
he took over Live Stream Fails after leaving Twitch and started
moderating it uh in in direction of like dismerging,
all of Destiny's opponents, deleting
Uh
I don't know if this is true. I get why he wants to run this
narrative. I just I don't see LSF as that.
To be honest, LSF is like giga astroturfed at this point. I think
that's indicating something different.
Like it's super in favor of Destiny now, but I think it's it's
There's different reasons for that that aren't necessarily like
Stale at work, I don't think. I'll also the the way he sort of
shaped it in Destiny's favor, if anything, was just banning all
the people who were like bring up his lawsuit.
And I do think I do think that's
probably going to have the effect of making it so only are participating,
right? That is like a filter that even though he might not like
it and even though he says, "I have a rule," right?
It does end up going that direction. If you ban anybody who's
going to like bring up the lawsuit, bring up his court case,
or or bring up the allegations in general, which are the things
you should bring up, by the way. Right? It's the allegations.
If you're going to ban anybody who does that, that has an effect.
>> comments that called out Destiny for procuring child
sex abuse material and regularly brigading posts, regularly botting
certain posts. Okay? Notice how I don't push back on that one.
I'll I'll never make the allegation directly, okay? But I won't
push back on that cuz I do think there's something going on with
some engagement on LSF that seems little concerning, little weird,
okay? Little weird. What is this? Look at the But again, do you
guys remember the the talk I gave Mischa yesterday, okay? Hypothetically,
the talk I gave Mischa.
what people have to understand is everybody is astroturfing now.
Literally, astroturfing is like table stakes to play the game.
Okay? I don't have the resources to astroturf significantly.
I try to get people to participate by going, you know, for example,
"Guys, go like the Blast off tweet. It's pinned in the chat.
It's really critical to the stream to the stream's success that
you like the Blast off tweet, reshare the Blast off tweet, engage
with the Blast off tweet, okay?"
That's a version of astro astroturfing. Always Be Clipping is
another one. Yes, you should get your community uh participating,
excited, engaged all the time. This should be something you focus
on all of the time.
Hasan kind of pulls away from that and he thinks nobody should
do it. It seems like, "No, you should be doing it." And if you're
not going to do anything about it, then other people are just
going to win in those spaces, especially in those more niche
spaces, okay? Yes. You You do have to compete for that. I would
say awk is a thing. The fact that there was no equivalent to
Ahk that rose up on Hasan's side, there's nothing close to that.
I would say that's a huge failing on Hasan's part. I think Hasan
has far less engaged, you know, core community members. I think
Hasan, and I hate to call him out on this, he he got no motion,
okay? Hasan ain't got no motion. He's got no motion.
Like Hasan should be getting more people involved. He should
have a core group of people who are like noticing these trends,
bringing them up to him, right? That you have this rise of Ahk,
and then it's just it's literally communities that all hate Hasan.
He's been retweeting Austin Ahk's. Well, it seems like Austin
Ahk's is somebody who's like starting to rise. Now, I think this
is how Gato Feumador got kind of popping off. I think it's how
Substance is starting to pop off. So, yeah, Hasan should know
about this account, okay? Substance. Hasan should follow Substance.
Hasan should be ready to retweet Substance at the drop of a
Okay? Hasan should be aware of this
Follow Substance, Hasan. Be ready. Be
When Hasan does that, people call his fans annoying. Yeah, well,
listen, I've never heard that about DGGers that they're [__]
annoying. Oh, wait, literally every community, even the communities
aligned with Destiny's, call DGGers [__] annoying.
Yeah, they're [__] annoying. Everybody knows they're
[__] annoying cuz they're engaged.
Every community that is engaged is [__] annoying.
Be prepared to get called annoying or have your fans be called
[__] annoying if you want to
The YouTube banner?
His YouTube banner is him and Austin? That's hilarious.
Okay. And he's made some videos, you know, over uh over the years.
He's made you know, this this last video that he made is the
one that's like going uh super viral right now, not on YouTube,
but just everywhere else where people are clowning on him. And
Chat says these videos always have self-deprecating inside jokes
that they're proud of their issues because it makes them feel
different from normies, that's all. Yes, thank you. You actually
literally analyzed it perfectly. A lot of these guys know that
they're in a cult or cult-like formation. They just make jokes
such as that one to be like, "Haha, it's not a real cult cuz
we're aware of it, okay?"
A big part of this is also making those self-deprecating jokes
about like, "Oh, we know everything about Destiny." All this
[__] right? But the reason why I'm again bringing
this up is because he took over a very popular subreddit and
played a formative role in the collapse of like Twitch as a as
a space where there was a major community that collaborated with
one another, greatly greatly heightening the tensions between
content creators like we talk about Clippers and clip farmers
in general on Twitter. LSF was the method. It was the original
place where that exact same thing happened where you would take
someone's clip out of context. Yep. Yep. >> And you would
have every single uh content creator on watch it and give their
takes on it, and then every single thing that uh would drive
discourse would come from LSF.
I don't go to LSF any longer. I don't, you know, frequent LSF
any longer because it's just all botted into oblivion and brigaded
into oblivion. But but they did this, and now Yeet does this
on Twitter as well in a similar fashion. But they did this to
go after Destiny's enemies and to try and present Destiny in
a positive light to the best of their ability even though he
kept, you know, [__] up his um he he kept [__]
up his own optics by popping off and and doing horrible mo- Now,
I'd say, I don't know how much of that is top-down. I think some
of it is, okay? But what Destiny has is people around him who
understand
how like online communities work, understand how to spread narratives,
right? And they're like militant about doing that in a positive
fashion for Destiny. So, I don't know with Yeet. Yeet came out
of Destiny's community, but I do know that Yeet would have people
like in his Discord who would consistently be giving him content
that he can monetize, that would be like inflammatory, and it
would be pushing in a direction, right?
Like Yeet is in that same group of people. He gets content from
the same group of people. I I I understand that,
Hasan needs people who are dedicated like that in his direction.
If he doesn't have them, he's got to figure it out, okay? You
got to figure out some people who are like dedicated to you,
dedicated to your content, and are willing to put out counter-narratives,
willing to support those, right? >> Monstrous things. Anyway,
also Stail in his Discord already confirmed nothing about LSF
will change, and all the other mods on the team are also Epstein
orbiters as Stail is the one that hired them, yeah. A while back,
there were a bunch of different people that were actually moderators
in in the subreddit. Once he took over, he basically kicked out
all of the people that voted against him becoming the top uh
moderator of the subreddit, and then he hired a bunch of other
moderators to operate the subreddit that were also Destiny's
fans. So, as far as I understand, the LSF subreddit is not going
to change, okay? >> Um this happens still, Destiny sucks,
but yeah, it's not the same anymore. It's not the same.
And I I would just say it's like table stakes. If you want to
rise up, you do have to like get people on your side, get people
posting your clips, get people like in your corner. You need
that, or else, yeah, the whole thing falls apart. Yeah, whole
thing falls
Don't suggest We do the same thing with you, bro. There is nothing
that even remotely compares to this level of of propaganda specifically
at the behest of one singular individual. Nothing at all. There
is no comparison. You cannot point to a single subreddit that
like my fans have taken over uh with my direction and use a subreddit
specifically to like attack people. There's no equivalent because
this is insane. It's so insane that if you were to actually explain
to people what is going on here, they still have a hard time
understanding it. This is the type of [__] that is
impossible for even like extremely online people because this
is a step beyond that. This is Kiwi Farms. It's lolcow-ing, okay?
For a content creator that actually basically derives most of
his content from trying to create oppositional figures and constantly
contest them. Something that Ethan Klein does as well to a certain
degree, but something that Destiny eats off of forever. This
is this is his primary focus. This is the primary content. If
anything, my community is my biggest opp.
Hasan actually gets it a little better than I it a little better
than I thought here. This is Destiny's only way to fight against
certain narratives. It's another reason I like don't cover stuff
anymore, like anywhere near as much, right? People try to say
it's like, "Oh, well, the court case is going against him going
in his favor, so it's like all fine. You you don't want to cover
it anymore." It's like, "No, I just don't want to give him like
the the opposition cuz that's all he fuels himself off of." Is
he tries to create enemies for his community, and he just gets
his community back on his side cuz it's like, "Yeah, I did something
bad, guys, but there's somebody worse." Right? Think of every
single major arc where Destiny's doing something bad, and think
of the villain that he built up out of that arc to like make
it so his community would never take those people seriously,
would never like actually look at him as the bad person, right?
Max? Lav?
Um Bob 7? Right? And all these people would have flaws. They
would have real flaws. They would even Some of them would be
bad. But Destiny's doing actions in all of those cases that are
obviously
as bad if not worse in a bunch of those cases, right? Melina?
Yeah, he but he builds up a villain. That's the only way he can
operate is by building up a villain. Obviously, the biggest villain
for him in his community is Hasan, and they have been to undertaking
like I think a directed like intentful campaign to try to clip
this guy's reputation on the internet for
the better part of 2 years now since October 7th. It's just been
like crazy. All right. It's been nuts. Hasan shocks his dog?
That he does, Scambanks. That he does. Anyway, anyway, anyway,
I I think um I but it's cool that he understands it. I'm I didn't
think he really understood it that well, but that is a good way
of explaining it, right?
I'd say the only person who I think moved away from Destiny without
that same villainous build-up, but then was villainized later
was probably Vaush. Although, I didn't really follow that that
well. Like Vaush seemed to be exiting at a time
like he he left around the IrishLaddie, like the weird Poppy
DMs, right? Is that when he left? I think Vaush didn't have quite
that same thing, but then Vaush was built up as an enemy after
the fact as well.
Cuz I think Vaush, you know, sold Reddit the guy. >> Okay.
This video explains [clears throat] the psychology behind this
kind of behavior really well. >> same thing. Okay, I'm
not going to get into that right now, but
but what I was trying to explain, okay? What I was trying to
explain here is that
basically, this guy uh utilized the subreddit LiveStreamFails
uh for his own purpose, for his uh favorite content creator Destiny's
own purpose, and you know, banned a bunch of people from the
subreddit and consistently botted and brigaded certain posts
against Destiny's enemies over and over again. In many instances,
leaned into like uh you know, propaganda that was pro-Israel
because Destiny's pro-Israel. Like I don't even know what this
person's like if this guy has his own
uh if this guy has his own opinion on things outside of what
Destiny believes, but like his primary purpose on LSF was to,
you know, whoever was [clears throat] saying like, "Fuck Hasan.
Hasan's a terrorist." He would boost it, right? Jstark, 2024
DGG of the year, was head of the Hasan bat propaganda with Dan
Stalkman. Even he says all of it was Stail was too deep in the
cult. Yeah, JSTLK was the previous >> Oh. What?
Oh my god.
Oh my god. My ears are ringing. >> year, and now I think
he is one of the orbiters who actually turned on Destiny and
is actively trying to pull people out of said cult if I'm not
mistaken. I think many of those guys still have like resentment
towards me as well, but I'm slowly but surely some people have
uh awakened
from the uh the the really toxic way that this cult operates.
I would say,
okay. Oh my god, Hasan knows your lore. Hasan is super plugged
in, by the way. We always say this, Hasan's very plugged in.
I don't think I have I don't have resentment towards Hasan. I
just don't agree with his politics broadly.
But in a way that's very different than before, okay? Um and
have realized that maybe Destiny wasn't the person that he uh
presented himself as. Dan Stalkman is the is the is the money
behind this operation. Jesus, they have alumni? Yes. It's kind
of. Kind of. >> But in any case, the reason why all of
this unfolded and he lost his uh cherished coveted position as
the top moderator of this livestream uh fails subreddit. Uh and
this is one of the previous uh moderators of the subreddit, Josephus,
who was uh who was ousted from his position when this guy took
over. He has also openly stated that the rest of the mod team
is still his guys and is openly taunting the Reddit admins. My
guess is more mods will be removed. Yeah. The thing is, Reddit
knows exactly what's going on. Like Reddit, the actual company,
knows It does seem It does seem Stail just messaged me. He was
like, "Oh, actually, I'm not going to come on stream now." Oh
boy. I thought I thought Listen, I just took this guy's word.
I knew that it was going to be dicey, but I just took this guy's
word for it when he said, "Hey, I'll come on." I kind of just
I took his word for it.
Oh boy. I
I wonder why he gave me his word. I literally I made sure I like
lined up my timing with him, too. That's too bad. It's Oh, so
LSF is doing this kind of stuff, right? And for the longest time
they haven't actually punished them for brigading, botting, using
it as a vehicle for harass
Stale Ran, it appears that Stale Ran
He did say he was coming on.
I don't do the channel points right away. I let them build up
in a queue. Um oh, this is my apology bit. This is um where I
realize you're super right about Hasan being terminally online.
Yeah, he is terminally online.
Oh, this guy used to be on the LSF team mod team. Okay. against
specific creators. Part of the reason why they haven't done so
is because it drives a lot of traffic, right?
It drives a lot of traffic to the to the website. It keeps people
engaged on the website. So, they don't really do anything, especially
because people don't actually push back too hard on it, right?
Cuz as long as you come after someone like myself and you keep
doing that over and over again and keep doing this like harassment
operation over and over again, um it's almost like a self-isolated
situation. We had a good thing going. We raised 40K for mental
health. Yeah. Um in any case, if it if there's clicks, then they're
happy with it. Even though uh they they had a tendency to overlook
certain things that he was doing like for example, uh operating
a mirror system where he would mirror clips and then he would
actually run ads on the website where he would mirror clips and
uh therefore make money off of the subreddit this way. I think
it's a it's a vio
I do believe that
I do believe
that with regards to Oh, hold on. What was I Oh, Twisted Rope
is saying like how could you not believe that Hasan was terminally
terminally online? Well, a lot of people claim that that like
he's not really plugged in that much. I'm like no, you're wrong.
You're just totally wrong. Cuz you can tell he knows like a ton
of lore all the time. >> violation of the terms of service,
but again, if you're a large enough subreddit, you can do some
scams like this without Reddit actually getting too mad. Okay?
Have you noticed that every roach king post is botted? Negative
instant downvote and positive upvoted? Yes. Uh this is something
that other
Uh did you see Asmongold react to you? I know you like that streamer
attention. What the [__] did Asmongold react to?
What are you talking about? Where did Asmongold react to me?
What was he What was he talking about? That would be funny. But
this must have been a long time ago or something. I don't know
when that would have been. People that use Reddit frequently
have noticed as well. Anywhere around the website if there's
a negative if there's something that presents Asmongold in a
negative light, it instantly gets botted get bot downvoted. If
there's anything that presents him in a positive light, it instantly
GETS UPVOTED.
OH, I SEE. I see that he's adding Stale. Got it. I don't think
Stale's here.
Or is Stale here? Wait, he doesn't have the underscore on here?
@stale Keep showing up in the chat. I just I think he should
come on.
I think he should come on. I have a feeling that he had no intention
of coming on. I kind of knew that, but I you know, I try to be
good faith, okay? I try to be good faith. When somebody gives
me their word, I'm like, "Oh, well, you gave me your word." I
try to be good faith. I tried to but you know, it is what it
is, man. Um the thing is that's not even Asmongold's doing though.
That's Kick.
It's Kick. Kick does that. Kick also heavily upvotes uh all the
LSF posts. It's not an accident that so many random so many random
streamers that are associated with Kick or are Kick streamers
have been uh frequently upvoted on uh you know, on on LSF over
and over
Oh, come on, man.
That's not true. Anyway, like I said, it doesn't matter.
He does a 21-minute video. There's full details of the scam and
his removal that was covered on another subreddit called Subreddit
Drama. Popular subreddit Livestream Fail mods and Mythic Talent
streamers were promoting a shady website and contest and users
were not having it. Then contest website and social media was
erased and the head moderator was removed. Popular streamer ExtraEmily,
among other streamers from the Mythic Talent agency, which Asmongold
owns by the way, I'm pretty sure, right? Isn't that that talent
agency that Asmongold owns? Started promoting a website and contest
called Million Dollar Fan. He's a part owner of it. milliondollarfan.show
now gone, but can be seen here. Uh with a $20 million prize pool.
Subreddit Livestream Fail head mod created a post promoting and
sponsoring the website and contest here. This post was now removed,
right? It was locked and removed by the moderator.
The user started saying after some quick research that this looked
like a scam and the moderator removed the comments criticizing
the contest. Popular YouTube personality MoistCr1TiKaL made a
video about the website and the content itself calling it feels
like a scam. He pointed out this content raised a ton of red
flags. The main image was AI generated, said the prize pool is
absurdly big with no idea who's hosting the content. Uh who's
hosting the con Okay, this is a lot of stuff we've already covered.
I'm trying to see does he He reviews the whole full video. Did
Asmongold watch the video as well? I do feel like it'd be funny
to watch the Asmongold video as well.
He's just jealous cuz Stale is a higher tier coder than you,
apparently.
Apparently. Uh let's see. I do Man, I do I'm trying to like convince
the guy to come on. I think he's trying to dodge getting asked
like actual inconvenient questions, right? That seems That seems
very likely to me that he doesn't want to get asked like, "Hey,
what was he doing diligence here?" I think I think that's probably
what's going on. contest and the sponsors are mostly unknown
or downright fake.
Yeah, I'm going to [__] your head.
Shouts out to Charlie. Shouts out to MoistCr1TiKaL, by the way.
Still calling balls and strikes. >> We have a lot of other
stuff to go through today, so we can check out some of the other
stuff here. >> unknown or downright fake. The concept is
fans submitting clips and they get chosen to go to a mansion
to participate with their streamer in an IRL contest and you
can also buy entries via the
Another post is created in this subreddit where the users criticize
ExtraEmily and the Livestream Fail moderators. A few hours later
the website and all social media for the contest were removed
or closed without any notice.
I think where we go after this is I'm going to cover possibly
some of the Chud stream from today.
I think he talked to Stale earlier today, talked about his relationship
with Nick Fuentes Dorio. I do think that's very interesting stuff
cuz Chud has been basically trying to pressure people a lot,
I think he's been trying to pressure people a lot.
Maybe just watch the funny clips. The funny clips of what? All
of Asmongold
All of Hasan reacting. Hasan left speechless after learning the
alleged real age of Stale 2000, the disgraced former head of
Livestream Fail linked to the DGG cults. >> or maybe it's
one of those guys that's like he looks 40 he looks 40, but he's
ACTUALLY LIKE 35. OH, I FORGOT. YEAH, I HAVE THOSE LINKS. Hold
on. I forgot that there's the food shops bit as well. Oh, no.
Oh, I forgot about that. Hold on. Wait, you're right.
We're not done with the segment yet.
is only 1 year older than me? Hasan about to go on a whole physiognomy
rant. Hasan's like 2 seconds away from a full full-blown physiognomy
like like looksmaxing rant about how like your soul maps onto
your physical appearance, okay? He's He's right there. He's right
at the edge. He's trying to He's trying not to do it. He's trying
to hold back.
Bing. Help. >> Guess his age, 43.
Okay, we're back to the beginning here. I do have some of the
clips on the food shops stuff, which just would be quite funny.
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. All right. All right.
Um we could look at the Charlie review the video, too. Oh, [__]
Do I not have
Oh, [__] Hold on. I think I think Substance clipped
this [__] anyway. I can probably just roll off of
Substance's stuff.
Substance, you clipped this [__] right? I don't I
realize I don't actually have the logs I or the links I thought
I had. So, give me a second. Actually, why don't we just Why
don't we just skip forward in the vod? What am I doing? You just
skip forward in the vod to wherever he talks about the the food
shops [__]
That'd be
>> So, the person that they went after, the person that
he found was some other random content creator, okay? for you
know, they're calling him a calling him a for you know, they're
calling him a calling him a pest and stuff like that. This moderator
that we are talking about, Stale, >> a little earlier,
okay? >> that moderator realized that it was very difficult
for Destiny to find allies on the internet, okay? And what's
so crazy about this What's so crazy about this is he was like
he was so high on the the amount of influence that he felt like
he commanded because he was the mod moderator of Livestream Fails,
okay? That he actually tried to find within Destiny's community
other content creators that he could hype up by utilizing LSF.
Okay? Straight up. He was like, "I want to find someone in Destiny's
community to make famous with Livestream Fails as a mechanism
to like promote them." So, the person that they went after, the
person that he found was some other random content creator, okay?
I forget what they're called. I think No, it wasn't Lonerbox.
Lonerbox didn't work. Uh Hutch didn't work. They tried to like
promote Hutch a lot. They tried to promote Lonerbox a lot and
it didn't [__] work. And I think
Uh no, those worked Those worked quite I think there's a whole
new thing and I I hesitate to call it out cuz I don't mind the
people that they're promoting,
but I Oh, man. It might just be that I don't understand it. I
do know that Relle is getting pumped up a lot by like some of
these accounts. And so, I know Relle is a good person. I know
Relle is like got a head on his shoulders. So, I'm like hesitant
to just call out, but there is like an account that's probably
closely related to Spider or somebody around in that orbit who
does clip these things and they do upvote them very quickly.
I also think
it's like interesting to me Aqua posts the same clips as well.
I would I got to tell those guys.
I don't know. Maybe I got to talk to Relle about it. A relevant
took the PV bag. Who wouldn't take the PV Dude, I wanted the
PV bag. Are you kidding me? Multiple times on my stream I was
like, "Sam Seder, NOTICE ME. SAM SEDER, GIVE ME MONEY. SAM SEDER,
I I can sweep this way better than all these people. Sam, please
give me some money. Give me some money. Sam. Sam.
Oh, it it is Spider? Is What's the name of the account? There's
like an account that posts those clips. If it's just Spider,
then that explains it. Spider makes money off of clipping people.
And he's got He's high energy, okay? Oh, is it only Spider? Is
that Is that just explicitly Spider's account? Then that makes
perfect sense perfect sense to me. Oh, okay. I got it. Hey, listen.
Spider's just trying to make his money, okay? He knows This is
This is the thing is you don't run stuff by paying these people
directly or by like controlling these people directly. You create
the incentives,
Like if if you're going to post like a a take taking down Hasan
and that massively pops off in terms of upvotes and stuff, then
you're going to keep doing it, right? It's just classic audience
shaping. Very very easy way to get this stuff done. Yeah, Spider
does grind. Spider grinds hard. >> was what? Food shops?
>> There was this content creator that was in DGG, Destiny's
cult, named Food shops, okay? Oh, no. Oh, no. Oh, no.
Oh, no. The The Food shops files have hit us on. Oh,
And his theory his theory was that if he promotes people that
aren't like directly related to Destiny,
Food shops is directly to uh directly related to Destiny. But,
yes, hold on. I was going to explain this, but I don't actually
have to explain it because somebody actually clipped it and posted
it. Bro, 700 views. This clip is just hanging out there. How
did Hasan get this clip? Maybe Hasan's got
Maybe Hasan's got
more shooters than I thought. Oh, my >> that he could have
more allies. Here it is. I mean, there's a full 11-minute video
on this. >> Even better. Um
the short so Everyone go make clips or whatever and post them
on LSF the top mod of that subreddit really wants it for some
reason. I don't know. Post like a clip a day and I'll play it
on stream if it's interesting. I don't know. This guy really
wants it, but post it on the hashtag clips and it would be chill.
Also, it would piss off Hasan and other streamers, okay?
And the reason why the reason why they wanted to present this
person as like a like a new content creator was twofold. One,
because they wanted to see if they could just like make another
popular content creator just off of this subreddit alone.
Could you imagine if Hasan takes the document that Dan has like
publicized everywhere and just goes through it on Food shops
as Destiny is like hardcore defending Food shops right now? Could
you imagine? Could you imagine living in this world? I want you
to imagine. And then I want you to Darius level. Imagine. IMAGINE.
IMAGINE. IMAGINE. IMAGINE. IMAGINE. OKAY, I want you to imagine
it because it would be
amazing. That would be so funny to me. As Destiny is like currently
banning people from his from his chat, threatening more bans,
calling other people anti-fans, by the way, totally cult-like,
all right? Pull that clip up. I don't have that clip off the
top of my mind or off the top of mind. Hold on. I can maybe find
it for my Discord. But, yes, I want you to imagine
if Hasan takes that document produced
by Dan and uses it to actually go hard on Food shops, okay? Hold
on. Let's see
Uh da da da da da da da da tape
Tape deck just posted a thing earlier today that is basically
that clip. Hold
Where's that? Gee, what? What are you guys posting?
What Who Why did you make this? I Why was this made? This is
horrifying.
That's just horrifying, okay? Why Why is that there? Why does
that exist? Oh, well, I'm not seeing the I'm not seeing the tape
clip.
Staring into the abyss. All right, we keep we keep going with
Hasan. I'm looking for the clip. >> Right? And the other
reason was because Destiny was running out of orbiters and running
out of like content creators that have at least their own organic
audiences because they were all literally attacking him because
he all of his orbiters and then them over and, you know, and
his orbiters' girlfriends, you know what I mean? Like, he was
just a horrible monster, right? So, so many of these other people
inside of this
I don't think that's actually true.
I don't think so.
Like, not in the way that you'd say it.
Right? Like, he's talking about the Lunar box thing. I think
Lunar box reached out to him. It's weird that he still hints
at that that that Lunar box thing is true. I feel like that's
just I feel like that's rough to me. I don't like that, but whatever.
>> that some of the members of said cult were like, "Okay,
this is a bridge too far, right?" How you got haters you don't
know about? Oh, dude, come on. I have so many [__]
haters that I don't know about. So, that was the reason cuz he
was like, "There's too much stink associated with Destiny. We
need new people to defend him, okay?
We need new people to defend him. So, we'll just find someone
within the community, prop them up,
prop them up, present them as like a new content creator that
are not like directly associated with Destiny to defend Destiny
on LSF.
1:17 is when he starts talking about it.
the short story is
Okay, sorry. I'm I'm pissing on a little bit here, but I did
want to get the clip out before WE IMAGINE. IMAGINE. IMAGINE.
IMAGINE. IMAGINE. It's a cuts a little too early. He starts slamming
his desk and yelling. >> possibility like artificially
create like a drama champion. Um and I would No, come on. [laughter]
What? Why? What's up? The short is is like, do you have like
clip style content? What I want to do is I want to see if it's
possible to like take take a streamer and post like a clip a
day of like some drama related content to livestreamfail and
I want to see like what that does. You know, livestreamfail gets
millions of views every day even even for like the small clips.
And I don't know cuz you were like blowing up in DGG and so I
thought like, okay, the audience would kind of like you and it's
like cool content that's tangential to Destiny but not Destiny.
Basically, I'm trying to diversify the Did I even remotely exaggerate
this, by the way? My summarization is almost verbatim. I mean,
I'm paraphrasing what he was saying, but like that guy that we
were just looking at, the the subreddit owner here, okay? That's
the one who's
Two, these are both people in Destiny's cult and they're talking
to one another. Uh you left out details. She is an admitted Oh,
yeah, I forgot. Um there's also that as well. Apparently, this
person got outed as a
Yeah. Uh so, the guy that like the person that the the subreddit
owner was trying to highlight as You love to see it. You love
to see it. Thank you, Hasan. Thank you. >> not mine. Drama
champion. Turns out that they were
You have to understand how funny this is. If you don't understand
it, basically like Dan decided that Food shops had to die. And
so, Dan took a bunch of like information on how she's And I do
believe he built his own document with it that he gave to I think
Parsec to cover, right? Dan wanted Food shops going down for
being a I told Dan that Destiny needs Food shops. He won't He
won't abandon Food shops. He will not let Food shops be abandoned,
okay?
So, you should You shouldn't do that. And I told I told Dan specifically,
no matter how this goes for you, you're like you're [__]
Either you come off like the person who he's built up in terms
of reputation that he's used to like kind of go after the reputations
of the people criticizing him, or you fail and then you end up
heading up hanging out with somebody that you've identified as
an about
Like, they have They have basically said they've actual sexual
attraction to kids multiple times in the past. You've built that
person up and now you got to hang out with them. There's no winning
this.
that's by the way On the flip side, though, from my perspective,
okay? That's just me winning. I can't lose. Either they all have
to hang out They'll hang out in like a group chat in like a VC
with a or or or
>> uh or you get rid of like the person who is trying to
like A-log my content and lie about and he like literally not
watch my content, just like stealing my content. It's just I
win either way. I'm always winning, okay? Uh dude, it's It's
good times. >> which is, you know, I guess it is what it
is. So,
so, it didn't really work. It didn't really work. It didn't work
at
Yeah, that seems possible that Hasan could have known that she
was a from before, but he's just making sure that everybody else
knows now. I could just see it, okay? Hasan's actually the only
turbo online person in his community and he's actually taking
some people who are less online and telling them, "You have to
send me this in chat, okay?" He's like He's actually directing
the whole thing, all right? Before his stream, he's like getting
his whole his whole docket ready. He's got the chat he's going
to message links to. "Link me this tweet. When I say this word,
link me this tweet, okay?"
Oh, [__] What is the What's the reality TV movie?
Truman Show. Hold on. Truman Show director. This is Hasan at
all times, okay?
This is Hasan at all times, like directing all the all the chatters
to send him the links that he's gone and found, okay? Hasan is
the one who's gone and found all of the links and he's like,
"Okay. Okay. Okay. Send me the link Send the link in chat now
so I can pretend that I don't know what's going on. Send me the
link now. Send me the link now."
He's both He's both the content and the director at the same
time.
There's like nobody else in his audience who's this plugged in.
He knows all of it. So, he's like, "Okay, now send me the Food
shops link. Wait, send me this old clip of Stailan Food shops.
Wait, Hasan, where did you find this? Don't worry about it. You
We will send me the link now. Just send it, okay?" Not out of
They admitted it, okay. She self-admitted. Well, it turns out
I There are ops that I don't even know exist out there, but one
thing is a guarantee, they are going to be criminals in some
variety, some way, shape, or form. This is like the the primary
driving force behind almost all of my ops. It You know, there
is a Uh I'm guessing Stailan asked multiple streamers to do this.
He asked me to do it like a year before this, but that doesn't
really disprove the whole like, "Oh, he goes to DGG and people
to do it." If you exist for a long enough timeline and you're
an op of mine, you end up getting into trouble in this way somehow.
I don't know why.
It's the anti-pedophile aura, isn't it? It just works. It just
happens, man. It just works. But, in any case, like I said, this
is like his theory. He's trying to to create like a drama champion
in his own words.
I'm trying to diversify the content I'm watching. I I don't I
don't get what you're proposing. Are you saying like
Do you have clip style content? I'm I'm proposing your audience
makes 30-second
No. Is there Is there content like that of me out there? I mean,
I guess like whenever I make weird sounds into the microphone,
they clip that. But, like outside of that, there's Anyway, so,
that also didn't work, but the reason why I showed you that is
not only because it's like another point of evidence that that
shows you how this guy operates, right? Um this guy, Stailan,
how he operates and how he's using this subreddit for like a
very specific purpose.
Is that it for him talking about Food shops being a I was hoping
there'd be more.
But, I don't know if he knows all the lore yet. I don't know
I don't know if Hasan bringing up Food shops is a W for anyone
other than Food shops. Um I don't know. Hold on. Wait. That's
true in almost all cases except one.
It is never cool. It is never good to be called like a by people
on the internet. Giving people like a reason to call you a is
never good. That's the one thing where you can't say all press
is good press. No, the press is not good, okay? Literally, almost
all other press is good press. The press, that's not good, man.
That is never good. Um to to you know, help Destiny out in whichever
ways he can.
But, the other reason why I showed you this is because it kind
of it kind of gives you an understanding of what his mentality
is, like the god complex that he developed off of like a crumb
of influence that he was wielding, I guess. Um so, it was only
a matter of time
until It was only a matter of time until he got into trouble
such as this. So, here he is talking about the influence he wields
in Destiny's uh community DGG.
I don't want to be an influencer. I want to have influence. There's
a difference. Dot dot dot. Talking like he's Orochimaru or something
in a online group chat that is centered around a cult around
one individual content creator who was, you know, uh been outed
for some Zero views, 1 minute. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. >> I don't want to be an influencer. Influencers
are clowns that dance to their audiences. Instead, I want to
have influence. There's a big difference. Bro, I worked at Twitch
for 4 years. People there obsess over the subreddit. I have been
meeting with executives about LSF. Yes, LSF matters. And yes,
people in charge look at it. That's the influence I am talking
about. >> Like he says, "Oh, I'm being over the top. I'm
being over the top. I'm being over the top." But every single
thing lines up, right? Like he could say I'm being over the top.
I'm trying to like be post-ironic.
But are you really? Everything you say is in this direction.
There's no There's no post-irony without you pulling back to
like being a normal person a lot of the time. Right? You have
to be able to have like normal conversations. There's none of
that normality that goes on with
Like when we when we make jokes about like Reddit moderators
and how insane like the loser mentality is that moderators have
sometimes. Like this is This is a person who is living it, okay?
In a community that is comprised entirely of people that actually
farm karma almost professionally, even though they make no money
off of it. This is a very real thing in an in an unfortunate
dark corner of the [__] internet, okay? All right,
like Orochimaru. Why did he compare this incel to him? Yeah,
LSF mods are getting paid to promote posts and nobody talks about
it. I mean, I don't know if they're also getting paid on top
of that, but
Dario is post-irony 100% of the time. No, he's not. I've watched
his video on overcoming like his uh mental health struggles.
That wasn't post-irony. >> This has been going on for quite
a while is what I'm saying. It was always an influence peddling
operation. Um but obviously he got so full of himself that he
he took a shot in the dark to make some real money, and it very
quickly imploded.
And I was reading the comments from like one of the mods there
that was talking about it, and it seems like he's completely
clueless on what's even going on in regards to this whole thing.
So, I don't exactly understand their role in this or like who's
pulling the strings there, the puppet master at LSF that's partnering
with Million Dollar Fan, but the mods don't even seem to be on
the same page there and don't have any real answers. Then going
to IRL buffs is like going to a barren wasteland. This whole
website is completely empty. It's like Squib were going to that
room to be all alone. This feels like it's a prototype that was
thrown together in like a handful of Oh, damn. Well, Hasan's
done with his whole rant on DGG. You love to see it. Is there
anything else here? Are we Have we farmed this out sufficiently?
We farmed all of the Hasan content from this. Are we good to
move on? Next segment.
Let's see. Let's see if he goes back to anything else. He He
does watch a little bit from Asmongold. Oh, hold on. More Stale
logs. More Stale logs.
associated with it, right? And what is the best possible way
that you can
step on you, um especially while I'm talking about this. The
point is like they've been doing this for years and years and
years and years, right? Um and it has never really stopped. It
hasn't really had the impact that they wanted, right? >> Uh
not sure Evil Johnny Bravo, but not right now. There's too much
There's too much fresh stuff, Evil Johnny Bravo, for us to go
and not cover all of the fresh stuff. I want to go through and
I want to cover the Chud stuff from earlier today where he talks
about the Oreo. Okay, I want to cover that stuff. And then I
want to cover probably a little bit of the Oreo's stream on Turkey
Tom. See where that goes. Right? Is that not what we all want
to see is how the Oreo reacts to some of that stuff? I do think
that's a very interesting storyline. If you don't know why it's
interesting, I'll help us I'll help you out, okay? We'll figure
it out as we go. >> um my audience is not diminished at
all, right? But they still keep at it. Because for them it's
like one day it might work. For them it or even the mere recognition
that this stuff is something that I'm aware of is enough. Because
at the end of the day, this is the guy running the operation,
okay? And this is his attitude. I don't want to be an influencer.
I want to have influence. There's a difference. For a lot of
people that go on Twitch,
the medium here is very different than any other form of entertainment
because there's back-and-forth feedback. You can directly change
the content that you're watching by communicating with the content
creator that is is delivering the entertainment. This is very
new. This is very different. So, there's a parasocial element
associated with it, right? And what is the best possible way
that you can directly influence the life of the content creator
that you're watching? Maybe hating, right? A content creator
that you absolutely despise. Me. Try to ruin their life. I don't
know if I agree with that stuff. >> being uncharitable,
and LSF turned it into a clip that got like 150k views. Nerds
on Reddit messaged me for like a week over it. All over a
Yeah. This is a [laughter] outrage manufacturing machine. And
the reality is like a lot of those clips that actually go viral
because Stale is right. They do actually the the the subreddit
does have the capacity to influence Twitch decisions, right?
LSF is the reason why I got banned for cracker for saying cracker.
Because they uploaded a bunch of clips over and over to be like
this guy is the biggest racist of all time, all this stuff. And
Twitch responded to that pressure. Didn't even think about how
[__] stupid that might look to other adults in the
real world, right? I got banned for 7 days for anti-white racism.
And that was because of LSF. Homestuck list. All these other
like all these people that have been banned have been banned
because they put it on public freakout and the comments were
widely different being like what C-word? That one? Lol, exactly.
So, in this like Okay, it's dude I All right. Oh, boy. Dude,
he does Hasan already commented on that that he sounds like Orochimaru
or something. He is like an anime villain. I just want to wield
power. I just want to wield power, guys.
All right. What are we doing here? What is this clip?
Let's do a little preview for this segment cuz I do want to go
through some of the stuff, and I want to explain my thoughts
on it real quick. So, here's a clip of
local hog Nicholas De Oreo was seen seething over potentially
Rational Chad coverage over potentially Okay, whatever. Chud's
coverage of his alleged friend Anam Beard to Turkey Tom. Sources
close to Nick say this could be due to the fact that he had to
skip his third right. >> Stale Bald Head just tipped $5.
>> the stark ass >> I was unbanned after they kicked
Stale Bald Head's Stale can thank Zack Bussy. People put mod
code of conduct complaint under his original post lol. Damn.
Well, that is interesting. Maybe we could look at some of those
Zack Zack Bussy posts or whatever, okay? Thank you very much
for the money. Appreciate it. Let me add another hour to the
stream cuz we do have at least another hour going here. Guys,
if you like the content, go ahead, follow on every platform,
join the Discord.
We should get more of the drama stuff going in the Discord. I
should be pulling more people in. I should be getting like way
more engagement there. So, listen. Join the Discord. Again, like
I said, you need to be engaged. You need to be militant. You
need to be ready to engage and be a part of the movement, okay?
You can't You can't be lazy. Can't just sit here with your headphones
in and listening the whole time. That's not it, You got to shape
You got to shape reality. You can't just be a passenger. All
right? Take control of your life by donating to me and joining
my Discord and participating there, okay? So, let's go. All right.
Uh oh, also I forgot to say, if you really like the content,
you can help it go longer. You can help monetize the content.
We accept kicks, okay? We accept subs. We accept donations. Exclamation
point donate in the chat. If you got a couple bucks, throw a
couple bucks in the pot, all right? Appreciate everything you
guys do in terms of monetizing the stream. Let's continue on
with the content. We're going to move into this Chud versus Nicholas
De Oreo, how this is developing today, okay? I hope that helped
put your mind at ease about the whole hair situation. One of
your largest
Wait, what is the first put your mind at ease about the whole
hair situation. What the [__] is happening at the
beginning of this clip? One of your largest gaming subreddits
on the platform because I won a stupid game of like Reddit mod
politics. But apparently Actually, wait. One more. Alexa, can
you give my friend Chud Logic some words of encouragement on
his hair loss? Oh, I see. Hey Chud Logic, hair loss is just your
head making room for more awesome. Besides, you're joining an
elite club. Bald guys statistically earn more money and are perceived
as more dominant and >> Oh, the viewers might come back.
>> isn't measured by follicles. Thank you. >> by
the impact you make and the laugh Did he just hit Chud for the
viewership? Oh.
Dude, that
That's the first land mine that he just stepped on that he didn't
have to step on. That's an unforced error. There are a lot of
people in Chud's community who are totally fine sitting on the
sidelines. If he's going to actively take shots like that if
he thinks I know what he thinks exactly. He thinks, "Oh, those
guys all hate me. It can't get any worse." It can't possibly
get any worse. He hates me. They all hate me. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. I I personally have been
very kind to Nick. I personally been very very soft on Nick a
lot of the time. Maybe Nicholas comes back into the light. Maybe
Nicholas will be fine. Maybe Nicholas could be And then he takes
that shot right there. Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Like yeah, he just he
just awoke something. He doesn't understand it at all. Cuz Chud's
got one of those communities. I would say like Queen's community,
Chud's community are very similar in that they've got like a
core of active people that like they they make things happen.
Even for Queen's community it's a bigger portion. But like there's
a core of active people that will make things happen. And they're
not going to like that at all. And Nicholas does have the least
engaged audience I've ever seen. Like they will give money, but
nobody's out on Twitter like like really sweeping for Nick anymore.
I'd say that the engaged audience that Nick had, the people who
really wanted to sweep for Nick, they like Queen and like the
small commentary people now more. So, he's lost his engaged guys.
He is sitting here. He is very much like a whale, okay? There's
like a lot of whale hunters out, and he is like a whale. He's
slow moving. He doesn't really He doesn't really have any way
to evade or dodge, and he's lost all of his defenses, okay? He
used to have a pod with him, and he's been he's been stripped
away from his pod. He is just a solo whale out in the middle
of the ocean that doesn't know what's about to happen, okay?
There's a lot of people with harpoons out right now. And yes,
this is this is exactly what it is. The area watchers are just
the H3 ladies now. He has no shooters. He's got no shooters.
The shooters are gone. The shooters have fled. Okay, his shooter
is like a 60-year-old man who hangs out in Discord and his in
his Okay, and then a couple wine moms. All right? Not even the
good wine moms. Not like the Candace Owens wine moms who are
going to sit there and they're going to feed you a bunch of of
links and stuff. Not even the Candace Owens wine moms, okay?
It's like the worst wine moms who just listen while they're doing
random [__] They don't really engage. They don't
really care. Dude, it's it's going to get dire for this guy.
Um RFC people still loyal to Augie? So, if Augie sweeps Yeah,
but the Hold on. Why are they loyal to Augie? They're They're
loyal to Augie cuz Augie looks at things fairly, okay? That's
why they're loyal to Augie. They're not loyal to Augie because
Augie sweeps and like does all the [__] He might
have swept in the past. I don't know the particulars of the Flamenco
situation, okay? I've heard that he's he was a sweeper in the
Flamenco situation. Possibly, possibly.
But right now, the entire time I've interacted with Augie, that
guy ain't sweeping for nobody. That guy is just
he's he's letting the content happen,
Augie doesn't sweep anymore. The broom The broom broke a long
time ago.
If it ever existed, which I again don't know about. All right.